the most anticipated World Championship
match in years featuring the two top
players on the planet has been building
intention game after game world champion
Magnus Carlsen played brilliantly in
Game one against challenger Fabiano
Caruana but when the champ missed a
couple of winning lines he saw his
advantage slowly drift away and at the
settle for hard-fought but frustrating
draw with the match still tied after
games two and three the players are back
to battle for that first taste of
victory
exciting game for action from funding
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to our World
Championship coverage of this wildly
anticipated match between American
challenger Fabiano Khurana and the
raided king Magnus Carlsen we're in
round for a potential 12 rounds plus
playoffs and so far the tension is
simply mounting as we've had three draws
with some twists and turns but so far
both players playing like they're the
two best players in the world as they
are and we see a magnus carlsen one and
a half points
Fabiano carolina we've had American flag
also at one and a half points I'm
Jennifer Sahadi and we are in studio
here in st. Louis and with rad master
yasser sarah wan what do you think is
today the day I don't know it's it's
deadlocked of course and the players
have been playing really good chess and
like you said at the top of show it's
like number one and number two and so
far neither player has been able to get
the measure of other of the other today
Magnus will be white is the second
opportunity he didn't show anything the
first time around in game 2 is to date
of the day well let's find out well you
know white hasn't been much so far yeah
let's take a look at the format though
yes for those of you who are just
joining us this World Championship
matches best of 12 games that means the
first player to get to six and a half
points will win the match luxurious time
control three parts thirty second
increment for the beginning of the game
and a prize mount of over a million
dollars a billion euros
yes indeed about 1.1 3 million u.s. and
the schedule Jim
well the schedule is very luxurious as
well you have two games followed by a
rest day and that's to give the players
plenty of time to prepare and do post
mortems of previous games right now
we're in Game four tomorrow is resting
we come back in November 15th for Game
five and six then in case of a six six
draw or tie the tie brakes will be
played on November 2017 and we have
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley to get us
hype for Game four and to also talk a
little bit about what else is going on
in the world of chess well four is the
magic number today and of course these
players know how critical it is to look
to take a lead now the matches
definitely counting down and it's a
short match but even in the history of
game fours it's been quite critical that
you take a lead early because people who
take a lead early generally go on to win
the match but first of all let's talk
about the ladies who are looking to
become part of the Final Four we have
the Elite Eight but things have been
decided at least in a couple of these
matches finally going down out young
favorite gully girl we call her she has
lost to jou engine and she gave a very
valiant battle but to engine the women's
world champion was able to indeed send
the youngster from Uzbekistan home with
a win to enjoin the only player in the
competition who has only required two
games to win all her matches so far
simply dominant in her performance
trying to show that she's indeed the
best on the planet at least the women's
world champion can she keep her title
also Katarina like know who had that
epic nine game battle in the last round
decisive this time - oh that's it
shutting the door she's in the finals as
well and we are family and I got my
sister with me the Moosey chicks are now
battling it out as an amazi choke she
was able to draw both our games against
castaigne so there
to a playoff and Maria Moses choking
needing to defeat the youngest player in
the competition
John SIA Abdul Malik she did win today
and she's also going to a playoff so the
two sisters will be playing side-by-side
tomorrow the two Ukrainian sisters at a
matter of fact so that's going to be
very exciting to see a little bit of
game for trivia we should point out
there have been seven count them seven
twelve game world championship matches
only one has resulted in a decisive Game
four and that was back in 2010 as an
undefeated - Paula in Sofia Bulgaria to
take the lead in that match and
eventually win it he by the way had the
white pieces does that bode well for
Magnus Carlsen today or will Fabiano
Caruana be able to block him and
continue this drawing streak we will see
as the game is set to begin
well thank you Maurice that game for how
pivotal it is indeed to these short 12
game world championship matches what's
your take on just overall how do you
just feel about the match so far Jen
you're satisfied with ABI how he's
playing um I feel like I kind of agree
with that Amir kramnik like I'm not
horrified but I'm kind of I want him to
get more with white and I love what
Kramnik said I I'm sure we're trickled
down to Fabien his team but I love what
he said about how he doesn't like fabi's
white handling with the rasa-lila not
only because he's not getting amazing
advantages but also because it doesn't
really fit his style mmm in a way I
believe he said something like that yeah
I can't remember the exact words well
he's a wonderful interview he came on
and talked with us for almost an hour
giving his his insights and as such a
great world champion that he was it was
just marvelous listening to his take on
the match so I mean I'm a huge fan fan
of course I want him to win and I
thought that it was close to 5050 before
the match began and I still think that
but I haven't haven't gotten even more
confident in Fabiano and it started well
so I'm waiting for that like moment to
happen one thing myself I do feel that
Magnus has at times I'll played fat be
pretty convincingly like for example
yesterday's game I really felt that
fabulous about to get something he
blundered with Bishop d2 and then he was
slightly worse so he has been getting
outplayed game one especially Game one
though they kind of like wrong what they
said really genius playing for magnet
absolutely absolutely genius yeah so in
fact this plays like that all match
what's over the point is its we're
deadlocked and no like that all game
correct so he did miss his chances so
overall I still feel that that's a it's
a pick a match you yeah I do
yeah and we're still waiting for that
tension to break and give us a sense
this is all five-year this is all Magnus
exactly and it's yeah it's thrilling to
see and it looks like we're starting to
get boos yeah right had a big question
yesterday would there be a need for it
would there be a d4 and I think I was
the one who said none of the above
I win yeah there is Fabiano and his two
games of White has played 1.e4 first
game Magnus when he was white went d4
now he's going c4 maybe sidestepping the
Queens gambit declined that's a zero
fraud yeah I'm getting two and they went
for a very straightforward English four
nights with g3 no beating around the
bush g3 on move to or things like that
just write down the that the main line
and we have a reverse Sicilian on the
board and Bishop c5 okay this is a this
is a move that has become popular of
late when I had these positions as white
and I had them numerous times I mean
it's just a simple automatic that
everybody played Knight b6 to get out of
the ambush that this Bishop on g2 is
looking at and there was always these
threats at night
take c5 so everybody and his brother
played Knight p6 their very very
recently Bishop c5 has become the go-to
move and we've seen a lot of elite
players including Sasha Gray shook from
Russia and now today in the World
Championship Aviano yes you're saying
that but I'm looking in the database I
don't know you're a specialist in this
variation but I don't see Bishop c5
anywhere in the database
I see three games Bishop c5 from this
position unless I have the wrong
position this is the position right yeah
Bishop c5 has only been played three
times in this position Knight b6
nineteen hundred times Bishop e6 first
maybe you mean it after Bishop e6 but
mission be c5 at this moment and also
been played three times in the database
we're gonna have to update your database
because researching because Grantchester
or then came castles and castles d2 d3
rook e8 and i believe were up-to-date
with the play after rook e8 last move so
indeed it looks like a Sicilian dragon
and reverse White has the extra move in
hand and this move rook e8 okay
oftentimes the bishop does voluntarily
drop back to b6 but the move rook e8 at
least intimates or suggests that
fabbi may be leaning towards bringing
his bishop back to the reverse dragon
absolutely normally with Bishop e2 right
Bishop e7 that you play rookie you work
a working one right and in this case
it's like it's kind of confusing because
I'm used to looking at this from the
black side me too but I'm used to look
at you're from the white side because of
an English player and I like to drag in
four black so
worth I don't hate the streets at all
for Magnus Carlsen I have no obviously
I'm on Team Bobby but when you look at
what he got with Wyatt aim in Game two I
think this is a wise choice
oh yeah well by comparison no question
about that especially since he actually
started having to grovel for a draw
almost directly out of the opening okay
so now the question is what should white
do how how to I don't know if increase
your advantage is the right term but how
to proceed well in the dragon normally
we're trying that we have a couple
different possibilities just playing the
simple chess moves Bishop do two rooks
see one bishop sometimes we're trying to
get our Knight
the c5 square look see one with the idea
either going through
efore or a4 and then to go to c5 and
again put pressure with the knight on c5
if this Knight magically transfers to
the c5 will be attacking b7 so there
should be two there's also an idea that
I feel like you relate to playing like a
three and before a 3 and B 4 a 3 with
the idea that let's make a move for
black for just argument's sake we'll
just drop back and we try to do things
of this nature with white my dad my dad
who's a feeding master always used to
joke because he was a huge good friend
of yours absolutely and obviously a huge
fan of your chest you can joke that you
would play before one of the top players
exactly minority attacks well a lot of
Sicilian players love to play a six and
B 5 and B 4 to try to win this pawn so
you've got two very good suggestions for
white how he might continue Bishop d2
rook c1 a2 a3 ideas potentially even 94
directly something else
what do we have let's update the board
okay oh my so it looks like we do have
Bishop d2 and then after night not at
all because I think normally the I'd
normally the common wisdom is if I get
to play B takes e3 I'm super happy
because I've got I mean pawn takes yes
dragon B takes c6 I'm usually really
happy because the B files what's better
than the C file the V Brock's all right
but here I guess the problem is is there
an immediate why why is it's not a good
way for me to play well first of all
absolutely the move Knight takes c3 in
the classical has always been frowned
upon don't do that you're helping your
opponent capture towards the center now
this B pond plays a nice role in terms
of attacking more squares and as you say
your rook comes onto the B file you get
some very nice play and that's usually
not offset by whatever black is trying
to achieve on the King side so the so
conventional wisdom is Knight takes c3
is good for white know ya work I mean on
the contour contrast it would be usually
Knight takes c6 is frowned upon for
white because of B takes c6 and black
has a bigger Center and so on and one
strategic reason for that besides all
the things you were saying is that
honestly blacks play in this position is
a lot of times to play on the d4 square
to stick a bishop on g4 and play Knight
d4 look at how that rook on e8 is
looking at the pawn on e2 as well so
that's a lot of blacks counter play when
we get to play pawn takes c3 then
goodbye counter play but there must be
something very concrete there that
induced Magnus to take with the bishop
because strategy wise we take with the
pawn all day I am assuming it has to do
with the movie for for black that's what
I'm thinking as well as that Bishop
takes C on me B D takes c3 the immediate
efore
maybe I'm not a big fan of this because
there is again this Bishop on g2
constantly in ambush on the long
diagonal here the bishop on g2 will hit
the rook and this night is going to
attack this knight on c6 but maybe it's
something based on f7 f5 this is very
hard for me to understand because again
the classics say don't take on c3
Maurice are we in familiar opening
territory is this all theory because I'm
a little bit we are a little bit
confused well we did update the database
yes and you are correct Bishop c5 is a
move or kudos to you as a english
specialist here in this position Misha
p5 however this line as you mentioned
has been played before and actually by
Caruana himself all the way to the
current position and this is a game we
did not feature very highly but we
actually saw this exact position before
happen on the grand chest or that is
this position with Caruana and Wesley so
all these moves rook e8 was played
Bishop d2 93 Bishop c3 and Knight takes
d4 Fabiano Caruana Wesley so Paris blitz
this year this year and Fabiano has
repeated the line the game went 67 moves
and ended in a draw so this is a
position from their game and Fabi has
decided that he in fact did like his
position and he has repeated the exact
same moves 93 bishops e3 was played in
that game as well so we have a position
that Fabiano is familiar with or at
least in a blitz game he must have
looked at the game and decided that that
position was fine for me and Magnus now
seeing it himself in practice for the
first night for the first time and if
you would continue how did the Blitz
game for the next 5 moves let's see one
was playing see what should be six rook
e1 Bishop g4 takes IDI for a3 c6 looks
like a very common position from this
particular
Black's satisfied looks that way all
right so then answer our question about
beat a c3 and now if you would be so
kind as to answer our question about b2
takes c3 because Bishop takes c3 those
elite grandmasters all recapturing on c3
with the bishop and we're looking at
each other and saying hey when when I
learned chess I was supposed to capture
towards the center this position has
only been seen three times okay in
history and in this position both times
two times bishop takes on c3 was played
okay and by the way the game the other
two games we have one game from two
players who are decent players 2174 and
2380 - but amateurs nonetheless and the
other game was a twenty one twenty five
against a sixteen thirty ooh
so we're not exactly you know top player
right this game was the 2174 with white
against the 2380 - he did play beat a c3
the only example in the database from
this position the game went on to be a
victory for black in this position so
really small very small sample size as
far as the opening is concerned clearly
two two two small sample size but after
BC three what was blacks choice he
didn't play efore he played Bishop g4 in
both cases Bishop g4 it's only one game
I'm sorry and only only one gave any
play bishops and the chess engine itself
does the chess engine II prefer beasts
to take c3 injury ship takes as played
by the world champion let me get the
engine up in a second I gotta find where
my engine is hiding okay thank you I'll
come to you guys in a second okay make
it a good one make it a good one a good
engine that is Bishop takes c3 was
Magnus's choice Knight d4 and I agree
with you gen if I had white I would have
probably recaptured with the pawn and by
failing to recapture at the pawn this
move Knight d4 makes perfect sense right
because what blacks blacks problem is
this long die
specifically this bishop on g2 is really
kind of its obnoxious pressure we might
say yeah it's just a little bit
obnoxious so from blacks point of view
he wants to clear the diagonal and
establish his upon wedge on b7 and c6 he
wants to play c7 c6 completely shutting
down that bishop and if black is allowed
to achieve all of those things that I've
just described it's it's quite possibly
it'll simply become better not
you know like he'll he'll jump past
equality and they'll simply have a
better position
so what white has to do something very
common a few more moves by the way be
okay for Bishop d6 Anna I think rookie
198 c3 Bishop takes c3 94 on board yes
and then V to e4 I like that that's a
game for Bishop e6
um Bishop Deane Bishop David sick what
what series what no this year oh I guess
it makes sense Knight takes d4 pawn
takes before Bishop takes before would
be Bishop takes before right well you
can win your pawn back but are you sure
you want you want Bishop d6 that is
correct that is a move okay now this is
getting weirder and weirder to me
because I was always taught that I will
happily trade my b2 pawn for your ePHI
pawn in such positions so in other words
I agree the materials equal but that be
- that there should be a white pawn on
b2 and there should be a black pawn on
e5 and of I was taught that if I as
white could trade those two guys off the
board I really have
or is that better okay sure that's a
totally legal move yeah cuz Bishop g7 oh
sure
so how does this change things oh I'm
the center no this is but now I'm gonna
get that beautiful Queen outpost oh
that's that's nice on d4 yeah yeah I
guess you'd have to just you have to
look at you know very very specific
ideas right I mean I appreciate what
you're saying there Jen that the Queen
on d4 so good I would if you if you step
back to defend the pawn on c7 or if you
play move like c6 before I'd want to
boot the Queen out from this nice I'll
put in Queen B - yeah quick yeah well
okay sorry Maurice Queen B - Oh Queen C
- lookie - we're so excited I could sew
so well once again Bishop Bishop takes
g3 Wow Wow
I think it's a massive improvement of
her bishop before I still think that
well I'm English player yeah desperado
though what happens after Bishop takes
g7 I guess Bishop h2 is just too strong
clear pawn shield but the thing that I
see is that as compensation for the pawn
structure here a little bit is you're
really ready you you you've got a rover
on I've involved worse than Weitzman
worse than black yeah yeah yeah because
I lost two of my kingdom shields you'll
only lost one right
right that's the problem Orochi eight is
fast yeah we're your idea I mean you you
you I mean it's everything is very very
Ella tempo right right very well
rookie Bishop g4 and said rook g8 really
that's slow dude maybe so
Brooke c4 give me a tempo against the
Queen thankfully and what do you have
three X or F 4 well right now I don't
see how your way Levi but I guess you
have F 4 Queen g5 Queen c1 perhaps
alright I can't get my King on through
it but also but how do I stop rook seed
for in the fence let's go back well I
can imagine Bishop g4 s being rook
seaboard
yeah really kind of fast rook C for them
Richard G for rook c4 with the threat of
f3 okay so just a second hold on maybe
just step back and forwards F for rook
c5 all look like challenges these are
for their ears it's all weird just a
second just second we're back here and
we're that we're looking at Bishop g7
right and this I don't trust I'm this
looks good
should be good for black after a c1 this
feels like White's King is a little bit
too open yeah I'm not happy about my
diction p7 wasn't a very good idea no
but well you got a look at it oh but you
got a look at it for sure but in this
position I would I would probably be
more intrigued by move like III with the
idea of trying to bring out my pieces to
the King side something like Queen h5
and Bishop b4 would be on my agenda
right because I like that
ship on d4 so beautiful but the problem
is you can play Bishop e5 just treating
it all right but let's kind of irritated
a well let's go back once more to our
mean by the way before you leave I just
our analysis with the engine please and
check out this line Bishop h2 Bishop g7
Mitchell Bates through check ok Bishop
g7 Bishop h2 check yeah Queen h4 check
back up back up back up
Queen h4 check King g1 and as humans
were quick to make the most natural move
on the board which is agent plays Bishop
g4 instantly bishop h3 excuse me
instantly which of h3o Wow with the king
yeah Rhett of Queen g4 winning or queen
g5 winning and now this position changes
dramatically whistles 1083 taken h3 just
Queen takes on h3 and now if we don't
have a good way there's a lift coming
over in two ways by the way cuz queen g4
check is a problem also forcing you to
the file if your bishop leaves right the
official leaves and gives h6 squares and
access and queen g4 check with the rook
lifting and suddenly the big attack but
it's like ow money in the bank in London
Colin yep I like this variation yeah
it's funny again it's like you know as
all of us are we're decent players but
we play like humans we capture back we
capture back and playing normally but
sometimes you have to stop and look and
say do I have to what else is possible
here and that visual patience relying
comes soccer and shows that black is
indeed fine in that line shows the the
two components of a great tactician in
my mind there's the ability to calculate
lines and then there's also the
creativity of a move like Bishop a tree
and clearly Bishop 8 becomes more of the
creativity side because the calculations
aren't that difficult no they're not
very long right once the bishop moves
back work e6
and or queen g4 and Riki 6 and I that's
why we study both you know tactics that
require us just to calculate but also in
game studies
that requires to look at you know
beautiful ideas right what do you think
is the bigger component of a great
tactician the ability to see candidate
moves like Bishop age three that other
people wouldn't see or the ability to
just brute force see more than the
average guy mm I I mean for me you know
like when I think of the great great
tactician and I think of Alekhine and
Michael tall I think of their
extraordinary creative creativity in the
sense of I mean they make a move and I'd
be thinking to myself what what why is
that kind of shocker just like this move
Bishop h3 is yeah you're going along
logic logic logic all you want and
patterns you know right somebody play's
a move that completely breaks a pattern
there's simply exceptional idea
exceptional as an exception to the rule
exceptional idea and and you're just in
awe like what are you doing what and
then you realize they found a wrinkle in
the geometrics the peculiar geometrics
of that exact position that works
absolutely works right now not gonna
work anything else or this thing right
this was off this pawn was pushed just
one square it'll all fall apart but they
find those kinds of things and they're
always the brains always looking for
that twist as opposed to the standard
well if I go here you go here because by
the way someone like Karpov is renowned
as an incredible calculator yes an
incredible calculator he can look and
look and find and just calculate but you
would never call Karpov a great
tactician right despite the fact that
he's such a supreme [ __ ] and of course
he saw his share of tactics as well but
that was what he did was not I was more
positional than tactical he wasn't
renowned as a tactician but those guys
liked all Bronstein for example yes same
thing would make a movie what yeah and
then you go oh it were ego it works it
works quirky and it works
yeah it's quirky and it works so that
original flair Jennifer that really
stands out for me by the way just an
announcement of our special guest
today's show we have a great roster of
first of all we have the founder of the
st. Louis chess club Rex Sinquefield is
coming along a little after 10 o'clock
a.m. here in st. Louis to follow up on
his interview that he gave us in London
we also have grandmaster irina crush who
is fresh from her bout at the Women's
World Championship where she got through
her first round and lost to the rate
each amp and then we also had the author
Fred white-skinned who Betty of Udo
searching for Bobby Fischer which later
became a major movie also the author of
mortal games about Garry Kasparov he'll
be on later today as well wonderful by
the way I'm looking at this game
position and I'm feeling a little bit
despised about the position itself
because this looks like a draw I mean
maybe maybe yeah so you could somehow in
enlighten me as to what you think about
this position but to me when you see the
Knights leave the board in a straight
laced position like this one where there
are no real weaknesses for one side to
milk and to really pressurize the person
then you just feel like what could the
guy do that's gonna lose this game
because it just looks very even there
are no weaknesses I mean blacks camp is
absolutely perfect the only difference
the only problem he has is this pawn is
under flight and I do mean very slight
pressure along this diagonal something
that can be resolved fairly directly
with the most c6 and after that how does
white build this position and turn it
into anything
I mean this just looks so equal just
triple zero everywhere you can look
nothing nothing at all in this position
imbalance yes there is this imbalance of
this pawn structure on this side versus
this one on this side but everything is
so solid the bishop is so cook how can
you how many Magnus is gonna have to
come up with some kind of genius ideas
in order to make anything of this
position Wow and yet I played for this
position
as an English oak with the bish with
without the Knights I must say I much
prefer the position with a pair of
Knights like for example in the game
position what happened was after B for
Bishop d6 I I would have jumped on the
opportunity to trade nights and take
this pawn by the way we could go back
that would have been a severe imbalance
that's yeah we got it right the other
the other thing that you've seen for
example is 92 and I refer you to a game
where it was Magnus Carlsen versus
Vladimir Kramnik from a London classic
where they got a position where for
argument's sake I know this isn't it's
the exact position that they got a
position like this where it wasn't just
for bishops it was a pair of knights is
what I'm saying now that seems to make
sense right lights on it keep a pair of
Knights on or if you're gonna exchange
like you mentioned with 19th d4 have
more of a severe imbalance in the
position and what we have here right now
the balance is so now from a material
point of view obviously dead equality
nothing there to discuss without the
Knights
everything's lateral pieces for bishops
rooks it's going to be very hard and yet
for white to achieve something but as a
Sicilian players yourselves you would be
very happy whenever you can get this
pawn to b5 so give me a suggestion for
looks like the c7 c6 is a play by the
way okay also an excellent suggestion a
six a four okay so imagine that I just
get a lot of moves for free so you're
we're gonna play very badly for black
for a second and I recall looking at a
number of games of brought bought viniq
I wanted to say and remember penn bruce
pandolfini on our show teaching
Fabiana to fight light bad Vinick
I fight like Botvinnik so this is the
maximum maximum maximum that white is
looking to achieve okay so first of all
he gets this pawn on b5 which
neutralizes these two pots so in a sense
it's two versus one on the key on the
Queen side with White Swan pond holding
back the two ponts giving me this very
nice majority of four versus three on
the King side and that's a genuine pawn
so for me this is a very nice advantage
for white and I've done nothing for
black I've just let I was about that I
was just saying that you so advantage
was desperately crushing right no no no
not desperately crushing but we have to
understand what it is that whites
playing for so he's playing to
neutralize the Queen side majority by
putting the pawn on b5 which every
Sicilian player knows you get that
Sicilian endgame then you get to play d4
and then you get to have a nice King
sight majority and in the meantime by
the way blacks pieces the rook on c8 the
bishop on c8 the Queen on d8 none of
whom have moved White's intentions are
very clear Queen c2 rook D 1 and D 4 so
we know what White's trying to do now
the question is does black have an
active plan or and the point of a 6
what is the dwell point of AC okay the
point of it is a 6 meant to induce the
opening of the a farm correct so a
Fabiano is for sure recognizing that
White's about to put his pawn on b5 and
he says okay I can imagine this pawn
coming to b5 when it comes to b5 please
do activate my rook for me let me play
865 oh I get it so how's it going to
resolve his Bishop wants the 8 maybe
he'll let the bishop stand there just
stay there
so let's say a 6 8 a 4 let's just been
played a 4 is on the board yeah and
let's just make one let's make lifts if
we will for
for fabbi for a moment so then we'll go
b5 wait we'll wait because we what are
you gonna do oh uh oh I I do understand
and so from fabrics point of view you'll
sit there and say okay my rook is a
develop I'm gonna lead my bishop on c8 I
don't have to move my Bishop let's say
I'll go Queen e7 as a for instance now
yeah exactly so okay so hold on so let's
go back I like white I think I think I
understand what white is trying to
achieve I'm saying what fabbi needs to
do is develop a long-term plan does he
want to play with c7 c6 it's a yes-or-no
question if the answer is no great then
how are you going to deal with your
Queen side how are you going to develop
your bishop if you are gonna play with
c7 c6 great then what what are you going
to do with your LightSquared Bishop is
it going to h3 is it going to e6 is it
going to f5 so you've got to develop a
long-term plan okay so let's let's talk
about this yesterday this is your kind
of position so I love it this is what
I'm challenged by it okay could we just
go back one move Sheree so here the
problem for black is this light square
bishop and also secondarily the problem
you're talking about is what's blacks
plan long term long term you talk about
the bishop where should it go but is
that more than that it's not just where
the bishop should go is after your
Bishop finds that square what's the next
move and what's the next book what's a
plan so the bishop on that five you
might argue that efore is the is the
plan you're aiming for somehow which I
think white actually wants to see happen
yeah based on what you just said looks
like white wants to see that four
against three happen
so then what else should to be attacking
on the Kings side should we be playing
for f5 and E for which looks super sharp
and crazy but looks like the only real
break in the position so if you're gonna
play with pawns at five has to be done
if you're gonna be black if you're gonna
play with pawns because there's no
unless you're gonna look for some h5h
for thing like what is black going to do
without his Bishop and a long term as
well to me it looks like you wanted to
neutralize whatever black was white
was doing play for c6 bring your Bishop
to e6 Queen d7 maybe play Bishop d5 at
some nice point and then this compete
with that Bishop on that diagonal but
with the move with this move it seems
like you're giving white a hook with the
move a six and he can wait around and
play Queen c2 and then play for b5 and
then try to punish you on the Queen side
okay so that's a I mean you know really
by asking all of the series of questions
that you were asking yourselves asking
yourself I think it really helps you
discover an answer so when you say to
yourself fool if I put my bishop on e6
then I really don't know what to do next
but by the fact that you put your bishop
on e6 you go oh now I understand I've
given myself two possibilities I've
given me myself the first possibility of
playing Bishop DD 5 to neutralize this
bishop or I've given myself the
opportunity of Queen d7 maybe
neutralizing the bishop in a different
fashion with Bishop g4 so that's why I'm
saying that once you you you you ask
yourself the question am I going to play
with c6 and if the answer is no then you
start to look for a scheme of
development that the answer is yes then
you look for scheme of development like
that I think black is gonna have to play
with c6 and it passed the place these
days why didn't I place these things
leave that pawn on ACE and a2 especially
right so now when you take if c6 then I
could play Bishop e6 with Tempe right
hitting the pawn on e2 well I would if
you start with c6 I was gonna start with
a 4 anyway but okay fine okay that's
fine so I didn't lose a move now I get
too much of e6 right yep and you can do
this if you like what would you like to
do after be fine so in every case I'm
playing for b5 I don't have too much
else to play for right would you play
rook e1 and before you you know you got
to go b5 come on ask your dad he'll tell
you long time English
or maybe or maybe let's go back now
because now we're developing a point and
maybe why he felt he needs to play a six
was because b5 is coming so fast with a
pawn on d5 that he's not the rook but if
c6 ba for what about Bishop h3 first
then ya to gain a tempo to get in your
next move
exactly so Bishop H that h3 so rook e1
rook e1 you've gained that you came to
you you gained a development move
essentially with your Bishop on h3 and
now Queen d7 and now Queen d7 fair
enough this all looks this all looks
very very straightforward stuff and
again it just feels to me like a lot of
the classical by the net games of his
his nice peculiar way that he had of
playing the English put a lot of
pressure on his opponent so c5 you feel
a5 is well whatever it is it is I mean
I'm I'm playing to control some squares
again you started from a very
interesting perspective Maurice which
was that the computer yourself where you
were going
zero zero zero zero as position is so
drawn and I'm sitting there saying well
you know like as a kid going through the
Scholastic's and the the Junior
Championships I actually really enjoyed
playing these positions for white as I
felt that I really knew what I was doing
and and it's not so easy for black to to
discover an active plan let's refresh
the board and tell me what's going on in
the game position itself
well two moves we got played a four and
c6 so those well there you go but but I
will also tell you now I'm looking at
the engine yeah after we had all this
bright discussions no useful to get the
discussion in look to see what the
engines think the engines hate a6 and
think that this book really is white
something to work for okay and think
that c6 is correct okay next
and after a for right I would start
defending like an engine
for Bishop h3 is correct that's the
engines move they love gaining Tempe and
now rook c8 getting off the diagonal
rook c8 getting off this diagonal so
that b5 walks into a real problem with
the c3 with the c3 Bishop now I suppose
that's true right because if I move my
bishop then you'll play B Phi before so
yeah I that is not the way to play be
fine now right
something like Queen b3 and I remember
what's the big deal I mean you're still
getting wait
your solo will whine your move b5 right
well well yeah but what the computer
wants to say is that black wants to
clear this diagonal right something like
this and what the computer also wants to
say is that by playing the move a six
you've helped white because you've
ensured that some lines are going to be
open up on the Queen side with a six
whereas the immediate c6 as suggested by
the computer means that you can keep the
Queen side lines closed well this all
seems like a pretty rich game to me
absolutely I meet you were I wish the
night night nights on the board would
make it even richer in view of what
Maurice has been saying by the way with
with Bishop h3 I might actually start
with Queen d2 with the idea that if you
do attack well it's just like one of
these things yeah you're saying that
lady see what is held off on e4 I like
that idea my rook would have been able
to glide over to see one where it's a
little bit more useful than on the
e-file but again let's see what has
happened in the game because a six eight
for c6
we've got this on board no I wouldn't
hesitate I play b5 but maybe I would
think about Queen
d - as well as a preparation for for b5
but ok what happens Maurice after the
direct b5 let's let that's the move the
engines really like let the clash begin
right pretty serious I I know personally
I look at the initiative for white right
here and it feels like white is fast
white is actually doing something white
is doing so feels really fast it will be
5 it's very attractive right now he
doesn't have to explode of course but
you were talking about this line and you
know after this capture oh it takes b5
and this is what this is the automatic
stuff yeah I definitely live for this
position yeah it's gonna come under
heavy fire yeah I'm going to ditch it
with everything off the board I don't
know I mean it's just terrible so I'm
the the quick move a6 really bothers me
man I mean it just Carmela hi water
whatever happens you play c6 and let
that position play itself but that a6
moved because you think you're gonna get
the a file to me white wants to play on
that side of the board and once the
board open so does it doesn't care if
you get the a file it's like so what but
to give white this hook now the other
thing about this though is maybe some
weird variation like let's play this
position you can get this move right now
this requires that you'll be able to
play this also at some point because
this pawn is gonna come under fire right
maybe you feel like you can fly this
down the board somehow and be a fully
distracting pawn that's now that's deep
if that's what you do now yeah now we're
in contentious Lane because that's
interesting so maybe that's why his his
pawn on e6 and he's and this is a
position Magnus will have to evaluate is
this indeed better for white this we
know that y can get the center with a
move like d4 and really blast the
position open and ask black you know is
this going to be for real especially
since you're going to still have trouble
developing that bishop but is this point
enough enough of a distracting force
this requires some very intense analysis
to see what happens maybe this is where
we should start our analysis
as a matter of fact cuz this is a
contentious position yeah it's
definitely double-edged I just want to
go back just a move or two here Maurice
just and I've gotten these position this
is a Zack type of positions many many
times in open tournaments against lower
rated opposition with black and what my
opponents would do to annoy me terribly
as I play b5 they would play a six takes
b5 I would play a four takes b5 and it's
like they seize a disadvantage they
would play Bishop d7 hahahaha
I would capture on c6 they would capture
with the bishop I capture with the
bishop they'd capture with the pawn now
it's five versus five it's clear I'm
better because there's just this little
button over here they're like yeah but
it's only one weakness they would put
their pawn on c5 they would put their
Bishop back on f8 and say look I'm the
lower rated player all I'm trying to do
is make a draw how effective is that
strategy 50/50 it's which was very
annoying for me so the question is is
just how big an advantage does white has
obviously you'd prefer white because you
know black has weaknesses white doesn't
but it is a kind of a cynical way of
play now I don't recommend that way of
play for and if for for for fabbi
and I agree with you that much much more
contentious where you're playing for
three results is the move a six a five
but I gotta tell you I do like white I
just take the engine they like they
don't think like that that had you all
okay if I figured out if you could put
York we don't need seven your position
can achieve flow as black pretty easily
because then you can bring your bishop
because your bishop become in a game
even on that five and look for you know
your chances there right and that pawn
on a five is a passer it's passed I mean
it did on the board pretty quickly yeah
you know it may not get there really
really really fast but I mean long-term
it is a passer as long as you can't take
it
yeah I'm not really know III again you
guys are the big Sicilian players you
know like what you like when you're
black and a Sicilian and you and this
kind of a Sicilian ish endgame you've
achieved quite a lot already
I mean on a good day you know Bishop
will come back you'll double rooks on
the C file
keep in mind Queenie for can sometimes
be really an annoying move for the
second player to face anyway by the way
quick question for the panel who won the
opening square image so far
do you like fab E's opening choice yes
no I like I like Magnus but I play the
Dragons have a bit bias okay well that's
okay you're acting like a huge advantage
so I feel like there's something
something is adequate for practices as a
dragon player okay and how about
yourself movies you're a Sicilian player
too I really feel like white is as it
one having as the edge can just wait
around and figure out the beef I break
because when you put a move like this
one with a six and c6 you're telling
white that I'm ready for your break
that's your idea if you do it right now
the white might say I'll just wait a few
moves what is your idea and I'm gonna
play b5 when I feel I'm good and ready
right and so my feeling my problem is
I'm challenged to find what white once
what black wants to do exactly and
really show what black wants to do
because I don't see any easy breaks this
is the only one I see it I'm deathly
afraid to because it just looks like it
opens up my King and I know
that my e4 push is gonna have any kind
of really effect so to me and especially
since it opens up the seventh rank as
well as well why it looks so secure back
here the next position with no worries
whatsoever so it feels like the more you
give him this it's like sort of the way
to play for equality is to play for
equality and now play for the dynamic
edge in this type of position that idea
of maybe playing for 85 or or what you
did you talked about weakening your c64
which I don't think Fabi wants to see
against Magnus necessarily know Magnus
the technician yeah I really think I
really feel like this move you know he
feels good about it he's gonna feel good
about the idea of being able to play
something like a five I don't think
opening the a five gives him anything so
to me White has something small here
okay a pair to play the minority attack
on this side this is what we're talking
about as a minority attack something at
least he can nurse I mean he's got play
yeah you know what it's similar to
yesterday in my opinion it's similar to
yesterday remember
Bobby had that small edge with white
right really small but we liked it yeah
I shove D to B to point a one
yeah we need Queenie rugby 1 and that b7
Paul was gonna feel the pressure right
we said you've got to play precisely
here and as a matter of fact Cromley
came on and said the same thing
he felt like father didn't do the
precise moves nurse it the right way but
we thought like that's the that was the
way to play if you had white it was all
you I feel the same way about this
position right now which one do you
think is little eggs for white and now
it's up to Magnus to show his real class
high level class how do I give a little
bit more printing to you as this
position continues now I I do think that
both point that they were advantages
yesterday that Fabiana should have taken
on a5 and then played Bishop d2 I saw on
chess calm very very very nice
annotations by US Champion Sam Shanklin
he's looking at each
very in-depth he felt that while white
had an advantage it wasn't serious
whatsoever that Queen c7 rupee eight he
was saying that Magnus would have been
able to draw yesterday mmm
it's a judgement call I did like why I
do like white today I think in both
cases the advantages are there speaking
of our u.s. champions hamshank yes a lot
of the time he's on Magnus's team but
he's not this year immunized yeah he's
actually had training camps exactly for
cardiac and burns itself but that's when
he wasn't playing an American so it's
kind of nice to see that Sam is not on
anything now and that's why he's like
doing some work I mean why he's doing
the analysis and sometimes that's
commentating as well sure sure sure
well I mean he's such a strong player it
I always felt that one of the things
it's a power yeah that when you know I
was up against the Russians and I was
playing as Russian players it was like
the whole country of Russia seemed to be
helping anatoly karpov for Garry
Kasparov at a time and I just felt like
well gee you know with fabbi there there
it would be really nice to see all of
the American team literally saying here
are some ideas go get him tiger
you know kind of thing so we got a lot
of reactions I noticed we got some
reactions on Twitter and on YouTube
about Nakamura saying that he wanted
talking Colin thank you was ready for
Magnus and I was thinking about it some
more as well and you know he gets the
question and supposed at his heart he
believed he does kind of what Magnus to
win whatever the reason or whatever yeah
you gotta respect him for not lying no
that's true I mean III just couldn't you
know let's just tell her yeah I just
couldn't imagine let's say ding liran
2020 challenges the world champion
Fabiano in 2020 ding Laurette and you
yang ye you know his greatest competitor
in China is asked who are you reading
for you rooting for
are you reading for fabbi ending and you
yang Yi says oh I want the American to
win his like what part of what means
this kind of Mori is his honesty his
individualism he hasn't ever really
worked with I mean he has this longtime
second Chris Lytle John be kind of he
kind of does here but he's in his own
orbit yeah I mean at one time he was
working a little with Gary that
relationship went sour but okay he did
to have a little but you're right for
the most part he's very independent they
asked him a question if he gave an
honest answer exactly though the
American players are gonna tremendously
benefit from Fabi
winning with France final yeah if I were
of that caliber right I'm no way near
but if I were like knock Oh Wesley Sam
the whole Olympic team really you think
was like listen we need to win this
title for the US of A right because
that's gonna benefit chess in the US now
after you finish when in the title I'm
gonna come try to take you down and beat
you right of course which is legit which
which makes a lot of sense but before
that I want to give you all my resources
and help so that right you will surge
and win the thing and make it great make
chess great in America right you would
totally agree but bring the Disney's and
the coca-cola be just one guy who's
benefiting it's gonna be everybody's
good be the rising tide lifting all the
boats so it's kind of surprising there
at least from what we've seen there's
not a single US player on Bobby's team
well I mean anywhere top elite player to
somebody player elite player on his team
I mean we know Rustom cousin John over
zonas to you al a very strong player of
course Christian gorilla originated in
Romania but yeah buddies marry me of
course these guys are all buddies and
work with us and sure but I'm talking
about where's the Weslie everywhere
exactly so ray Robson Sam shank honey
karai Maura the Olympic team
I will tell you something and I really
really do want to say I admired Viktor
Korchnoi greatly for this
he loved youth he loved passion he would
have a Jeffrey Zhang on his team
aha because you want you know that 17 18
19 year old guy saying hey why don't you
play this you know like you know with
with you know passion so if I had been
advising fabbi I would say you know get
a young person on your team who when
Sergey was like Sergei kiriakos like 12
years oil and he he was a coach for a
world champion contender or something
I remember it was somewhat was it Yvan
Chuck I'm just not 100% sure but I
remember he was like the youngest coach
in the history of the game you know for
a world so I'm one of them you mean yeah
I'm just saying that
fabbi needs or should have had that kind
of support just like well I will say
here guys when I think about Bobby's
team and the guys he's the guy guys
around he's got a great team there's
also his these people he's very
comfortable with yeah exactly
people you can trust 100% nobody betray
anything in that in that right no fun
nothing to worry with that's that's also
important people you've known for years
and you just feel great about a good
high quality high character individuals
that you battle-tested and you know you
know these are my boys you know we go to
war together and I don't have to think
about anything at all they're gonna live
and die a ride-or-die you know that's
right of attitude so that you can see in
that lineup that's just great buddies
yeah I think it seems like he's got a
great team indeed but we are gonna take
a quick break as I just want to say
before we take a quick break I just
wanted to say that we do have this move
rookie one and I see this move rookie
one as a preparation for a completely
different approach not to go quickly be
five
but to go quickly efore followed by d4
and remember I was talking about trying
to get a king side majority and using
your queen side my only so rookie one a
little bit of a devilish kind of move to
set up a long-term strategic plan but
yes indeed we're going to go on break
and before we go on break remind us
again who our guests are going to be
well we have a chess co-founder of Xing
field couple you up after the break to
follow up here is do you yes he will be
yeah and then we also have I read a
crash and Fred white scan coming on
later in the show Oh wonderful so stay
with us we'll be back in in a few
minutes think about the match in my
opinion it's difficult to it will be
probably more interesting than the games
I I believe they will be more
interesting than the match Carlson
against Kuryakin but at the same time
it's difficult to say who is the big I
don't think it's it's quite level except
if they reach a tie break and then I I
could see an advantage for magnums I
feel think Magnus is the favorite just
because he has the level of experience
but and anything can can happen I think
one small lack of attention and one
small lack of focus and distraction from
from Magnus can be all the different he
came very close to qualifying in 16 and
I felt that he wouldn't have been a bad
bad challenger in 16 I feel grown and
improved since
and also I think stylistically he is a
very interesting Challenger from
London's because I think this much will
be very very unlike the previous one in
terms of the way the challenger
approaches trying to win it because sir
gays approach was very much containment
I think it's extremely unlikely it will
be honor will be doing any anything of
the sort I think it will be much more
open open contest with people going at
each other a lot harder
I think people people are very very
excited for for further for the match it
should be a very interesting spectacle
well it will be very difficult first of
all because mangas plays also very good
in a rapid chess and so he will not be
afraid of dialects and and Fabiano is
more focused on a classical chess engine
in rapist also I can say that I can sail
some secret to Faviana with discount
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the world
championship edition of today in jakka's
we are getting into this game for battle
between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Carolina Magnus a plane with the white
pieces we're liking his game well it's
been a reverse Sicilian where black has
no King side attack so for sure it's one
of those positions that it's easy to
like white but every time you think well
there's something serious it's very very
hard to prove so still a quite a
balanced position I want to say but a
smidge of something for white normal
white advantage I'm normally swing into
the game you wouldn't expect right we're
just gonna go back up a couple of moves
we've got this position and quite
frankly we were all expecting the move
b5 to appear any moment
Magnus decided to do a slow play slow
played the position with the move rook
e1 which to me fainted with the idea of
playing efore and d4 in order to get a
central pawn majority after the move
Bishop d7 I expected efore but came
again in this very slow play III Queen
f6 and now Bishop a4 so white is looking
for opportunities to playing d4 perhaps
even f4 and maybe even Queen h5 I think
it's time that Fabiano started to
respond a little bit more aggressively
and and this moment I've been looking at
the move Bishop f5 I see this bishop in
the center of the board on e4 where it's
eyeballing the Queen side as well as the
king side I want to get rid of that
bishop if I were black I don't want this
bishop to to hang around you always got
to deal with this move f4 like you were
saying right oh we think that after
Bishop f5 f4 right away
you don't like the looks of it I don't
know I feel like I'm in exposing White's
King a little bit now I feel bad about
the move rook e1 you know like I wish my
Rick or an Athlon yeah you might think
that the rook on b1 should be on f4 I
did want to do I would be like crushing
here I can play like that yeah I put my
Brooklyn rookie and a half oh it would
be a great great player like that if you
could combine control of both files some
blitz layer through do that all right
right and only later when do they
clarify okay so I am expecting a little
bit of you know coaxing in the position
I would have thought and another
approach again I keep invoking his name
but Michael bought van egg these types
of positions again were the positions
were I felt that bad Vinick was in a
class by himself and he he really
nurtured advantages from these types of
positions so we'll see if it's something
that Magnus can achieve but we have a
special guest Jennifer but you know that
this is Magnus's cup of tea a small
advantage but Bobby has been defending
very well this year and not just this
game but this whole year ya know it has
been fabbi so fabulous year for favi I
was from from Berlin onwards but we do
have a special guest in the studio he's
back from London st. Louis chess club
founder and president or Xing field is
with Maryse and we know Rex is an uber
fan having become a fan of chess since
the 1970s when Fischer Spassky Rex
you're now seeing this dream again of
American players as Fabiano Caruana now
plays for the World Championship what
were your impressions over in London
well you're absolutely right first let
me say at the outset when I called in
the other day I forgot on his name and I
apologize for that that was just sort of
a sudden brain freeze and no offense was
intended and of course the tremendous
following this she and Judith have is
testimony enough is incredible testimony
to how good they are what they do and I
also want to wish our ability at happy
birthday I understand yesterday was her
birthday yeah
and so Joe and I were over there and it
was fascinating just to be on the site
of a world championship but we had an
extra duty you know we had to observe
carefully how they do things there and
they do a good job it was an impressive
layout because maybe was sometime within
the next six years I I think and I hope
we'll be in a position to host a World
Championship match and so I was I have
to tell you I was like a kid doing
homework psych all right let's see how
they do this in each and every room they
had a lot of breakout rooms they had a
lot of video presentation rooms and
press rooms and so a lot of thought and
effort went into that and I commend them
for it you were something of a celebrity
over in London we hear people were
coming up to you and nasan for
autographs selfies and you expect any of
that no actually I didn't I was quite
taken by surprise I think the first day
I was there I gave two or three
interviews but the second day I planned
to go there and just enjoy it sit back
and watch the match and I ended up
giving 9 interviews to reporters of
different press from you see you they
were witty harrelson and some of those
interviews being given yeah well I told
Woody Harrelson if he's really fond of
chess and that he should come to the st.
Louis chess club because even Garry
Kasparov says it's one of the most
important in the world and I said if you
don't believe me call Gary so but yeah
it was press all over the place they
were very very cordial and nice but some
of them were a lot longer than I
expected and what was funny is someone
came up a lady came up from Norway chest
and I'm from Norway I'd like to
interview you and I said well you folks
interviewed me yesterday if she said no
that was the other channel there our
competitor I found me it's so amusing
and heartening is it well do you this
two channels from one country that's
wonderful for chess and did you tell
them that you're rooting for your boy
Fabi you know I had I felt I had to be a
bit discreet but when asked directly I
would say that of course but I wasn't
out waving a flag for anything or trying
to be in their face we did see a picture
of you earlier well yeah that's
that was different and how did you feel
about Fabiano's composure demeanor
specially game one looked like he was
gonna die it did yeah I can pull that
off
right and I remember if I recall
correctly yasser saying if he plays rook
g3 the round is over yeah Rob's
immediate suggestion while he was on
skype yeah and and of course I was
looking at the computer too and they had
him down two point seven or two point
seven one and I go oh man I said this is
awful and then when Carlson retracted
that rook rather than her playing it to
g3 I said maybe there's a shot here they
had a chance otherwise he looked
historically strong to me really just
like Sphinx like fixed a cool cucumbers
they say I'm I'm very optimistic by what
I observed in his demeanor you were
there for two games right two games
right after the second game yeah the
second game he was doing all right with
the black bees he was doing all right
not only was he doing all right he was
reeling off those moves really fast and
I think the message was sent that hey
I've been here before I know this you
know do you get a sense in London that
one that the fans are rooting for one
side or the other is it like what's the
buzz in London around chess right now I
heard some people saying go Fabi but
otherwise most people were there
watching and not revealing what they
thought and any of the banter was more
about what the game was at the time not
who they were rooting for so I wasn't
able to pick up much of that but to the
extent I did I think there was a pro-us
sentiment I can't say throughout but I
certainly sent some of it that you would
think it's not like when Nigel short
play that Nigel played in 1993 with the
artists borrow of that London would be a
buzz of the chess fever this one is
seems like it's more more reserved more
reserved well thanks so much for joining
us we appreciate you coming in and
giving us your insight as to how London
was and we look forward to rooting for
the match the way you are that's right
thank you very much one just to confirm
this was your first World Championship
match experience you never went to
Karpov Kasparov in New York or Kasparov
Anand in New York he never visited a
wheelchair no they don't the last one I
visited live was dinettes and zürcher
toward okay that's exactly right
you had to work out the final details of
the rules and regulations no I get that
part but that's incredible that you
never been to a World Championship yeah
I guess I felt the same way about the
Olympia that I'd never been to one until
about cool two years ago but to think
that you've never been to a World
Championship is pretty work yeah they
did a good job projecting on the stage
observing the big glass separating the
players from the audience I wondered
what it was like behind the glass you
know on the second gate de Carlson puts
on a heavy jacket over his suit coat and
that was the first day I apologize kind
of sing boy it must be cold in the
second day he comes in he takes off his
suit coat it's just playing in a shirt
I'm saying I think they have HVAC
problems here what's the final score
predict it I didn't hear any such
predictions over two-to-one Fabi two
wins one loss yeah in restaurant yep Oh
tiebreak oh I pray no tiebreaker that's
the line anyway yes yeah two to one
sounds like a really good pick actually
yeah two wins to one win
Thank You Rex welcome home welcome home
yeah nice to have you with us especially
here in studio it's snowing outside here
in snow and st. Louis because it's kind
of like the combination of fall and
winter right yeah so somehow we kind of
buzz by the fall we were just straight
into the winter now let's get into the
game like I was saying
Magnus decided to put a slow play it
with a move rookie one fabbi went Bishop
d7 he said okay let me bring my pieces
off the back rang
and with this move Bishop efore as I was
mentioning White's beginning to say okay
I've got my bishop on this really nice
centralized square okay that be said
let's trade off those light square
Bishop and I think we're up to date with
with the play Jen we could easily see
the smoke Queen f3 a move I had
mentioned a moment or two ago but this
strikes me as a rather balanced position
Maurice what did the engine say about
this one because with the light square
bishop scumming off that bishop on g2
that was the pride and joy Wells gonna
get traded I don't see a big edge you
give you give Bishop takes Queen f3 the
engines actually get Bishop e6 as the
prime way to play
we're in Rosa bishop takes on e4 filling
that after Queen takes takes and takes
this position is a little H they think
is significant edge really well now
starting to reevaluate a little bit this
position there is this possibility of f4
b5 is still in position it really
doesn't look like that much to my eyes I
agree with you I say so did it did
Magnuson slow play by not playing b5
right away
cost-wise no question that's exactly
what happened whether or not it cost him
an edge is a different question because
this is one of those build them up
positions right he's trying to go for
and black history on and neutralized
before doing anything else as as we
mentioned it's not easy for black to
execute any pawn breaks or find a way to
build up any kind of attack against
White's King White's King is perfectly
safe
in the main position which we have here
let's go back actually the position we
have here as I take off my auto-update
alright so here Bishop f5 Queen f3 has
in fact been played by Magnus so this is
on the board Bishop takes e4 is also on
the board has it okay so Bishop takes
not were not Bishop e6
as the computer wanted alright so Bishop
takes e4 played as well so a couple more
pieces coming off that light square
bishop that gives that pressure on the B
line coming off as well making b5 a
little less potent of course because of
this pressure that we're seeing
disappear from here so this position
it's that same thing we talked about
about the linearity of the pieces that
are remaining on the board no nights no
nights or at least some kind of
discrepancy bishop versus night or just
a pair of nights on the board the
Knights are the Joker's in chess the
wildcards and whenever they leave the
board and it's a straight line pieces it
becomes not so easy to attack points in
a position unless you just simply have a
direct play on it and if you don't then
generally speaking is easy to suppose
your pieces and defend and those in
games are generally drawn so you have to
be really precise really exact and also
really dynamic in your playing which is
why as we were talking about the little
b5 get that in get flow going get it
quick get something that shows that the
pieces are your piece is gonna dominate
another piece like that Bishop that was
on that long diagonal in this case if
you lose such a bishop the question now
becomes now what at least there's some
structural issues on the Kings side at
least there's that in the position but
the more you look the more you feel like
blacks should be able to handle himself
in this kind of position and we do have
that endgame by the way of Queen takes
f6 has been played we're anticipating
gf6 and III takes de d3 takes e4 yeah
this ending and with this double set of
double pawns but this just doesn't feel
like any kind of advantage for white to
me I I just don't see how Magnus is
gonna squeeze anything out of this
doesn't mean that he's not gonna try as
we know Magnus loves to play long long
long long games but you know you look
and look and you say well
the advantage in the position for white
I'm having a hard time seeing it so it's
not what it's what would you have
preferred magnets to do to get a little
bit more to chew on well I I think that
his play has been too hesitant rookie
one was fine but I didn't like III
Bishop before a couple of moves just let
it slip here I can just see that black
is ready to bring his king over to the
center put a rook on the D file and
maybe even one day play for b5 and
that's a that's a majority over there on
the Queen side it's it's legit I don't
see why it's not a three result game by
the way we have a phone caller hello
welcome to the show our first phone call
of the day yeah Charlie think we know
you well I got my two questions that
this short but one of them is about you
said earlier in the match that round six
and seven one point we're getting two
whites in a world I just want to know
what the reasoning for that is but then
my second question is I read an indie
Psaltis is common a New York Post about
that thinking of changing the scoring
systems with drawers and wins and give
extra points for a draw in other words
like instead of given a half point
giving more you know war points I was
wondering what you think about that
change sometimes change using good just
to change I was wondering if you thought
it was good to play it was war that that
would prevent more more drawers which in
some cases like this match well I won't
for tours and you know I think mine is
or thinking I just wanted to see what
you have to say thank you thank you for
the question I think your first crack at
it I'm not sure about the anti Soltis
column that and specifically about the
drawers but I am aware about the Norway
chests change of the rules coming up
next year and the idea is that in the
classical game the scoring system will
be that if you win you get two points
and if the classical game is a draw each
player will get one point but then
they'll play an immediate Armageddon
game for another point so
I think it's a very innovative and an
exciting format and I'm looking forward
to it I think it's going to be really
really cool and it will really shake up
the world of chess if it proves to be
popular it's already popular with me and
they haven't even tested it yet so we'll
we'll keep our eye out on that then as
far as the world championship match is
concerned in the format of course from
in the last 500 years or so whenever
you've had a match you had alternating
colors so if you started with white and
there was an even number of games to be
played your opponent would have the last
white so somewhere around I'm gonna say
their comp ominous era and fidei they
decided to create a World Chess
Championship committee and those guys
are typical whenever you create a
committee you empower people to do
stupid things and the World Chess
Championship Committee decided like hey
look now that we have the power to do
something we have to do something so
they decided in their brilliance that
one of the ways they could shake up a
match if there had been lots of draw say
the first six games are drawn oh I know
we're gonna give a player two blacks or
two whites in a row to provoke a crisis
in the match and somehow they got this
passed by the General Assembly and the
players have always been too weak to
really give an argument against these
fidei administrators
so today the rule has been is that game
six and seven right players keep the
same colors and that means that this is
a three White's out of four games right
now for Magnus Carlsen yeah that's right
she's gonna get a crack in six and seven
as Fabi plays his last wait for a little
while on on Thursday it's a so what do
you think about this and why why do you
hate
so much because you certainly don't seem
to like this you prefer they just the
pure alternation right of course
I mean this is just creating a solution
where there was no problem I'm creating
a problem where there I mean on the face
of it if that goes the full distance it
seems so fantastic for the player who
starts with white because not only do
they start the first game with white
they end the tournament with white yeah
I assume the logic behind it is that if
for some reason it doesn't go the whole
distance then you offset starting with
white with the fact that you're actually
gonna have one fewer white if the game
goes 11 games that must be the logic
right I'm glad logic see days few days
rules and regulations I mean I but what
we SPECT
what would you prefer start with lighter
tutoring these rules just sorry I know
but if you yeah
Magnus got the chance to choose and he
chose black first I think it was just a
drawing of law I think I read it well I
believe I read that he he got the right
to choose by drawing the right lot and
then black and that must be why because
it's a game match last 11 games he'll
have the extra white right direct so
that must be why he chose it just like
game theory wise if white is an
advantage you know that you're gonna
play the first few games right so it's
okay to have less white then yeah but
since you don't know if the game 12 is
actually gonna be played you might as
well try to give yourself one more life
with game eleven then you know Maurice
you want to jump in there on Charlie
crushed memory so saying we we handled
it just perfectly okay and we do have
some more moves by the way after the
trade happened by the way the very
immediate bee7bea fibe I thought BR no
he got that move in and I can understand
his desire to do so by playing the move
B 7 B 5 he does fix this pawn on b4 on a
dark square I thought that he might be a
little bit more inclined to get his cane
to the center and after rook D 1 I think
we're up to date with the play I would
imagine just simply rook d8
and well I just don't see any reason
that fabbi shouldn't be
she should be unhappy with his position
this majority on the queenside is it's
it's a legit opportunity of getting a
passed pawn over there Maurice what what
are you looking at over there that's a
completely different position what do
you got for us well you know as usual
the ladies give us the fun stuff of
course and played some exciting games
today in the Women's World Championship
the second round of the quarterfinals
that saw jus engine move on and also so
Katarina like no move on as well but I
was looking in this position because
this was such an exciting game the young
player guru a game talk he'll Joe Nova
she gully girl as we call her she just
regale us with her play it's a fantastic
personality upsetting player after
player after player but then she faced
off against the big dog two engine who
is the reigning women's world champion
and Julianne Jeanette coasted through
all her games so far and this game she
did win after a long game it did take 81
moves to complete but it should have
been much quicker and this was a dynamic
moment in the game when after Knight f6
Julianne with the black pieces b5
getting in this move Bishop e6 suddenly
getting all the play in a petrov as
white did not play quickly enough and
giving black the initiative so she went
for it with night h4 she had to actually
go for it even more so than engine see
with the move g4 just go all in but she
tried it this way Knight h4b takes e4
Bishop f5 and this was a moment when I
actually came into the game as I was
preparing to come here for work this
morning I came in at this moment when
there should be five was on the board
and I'm looking at the position I'm like
well I don't know what exactly is going
on is at 396 and as I'm trying to get my
bearings about the position Joe and Jenn
dropped Knight d5 on the board and then
I was really awake
whoa wait a minute because this threat
on the night is won but the threat of
Bishop g5 was another was absolutely
serious and crisis mode
suddenly for white how do you deal with
both these threats particularly the one
liturgy five you can't just move your
king because you hang your knight
straight so a big problem for her here
now she tried to mix things up with
Bishop takes c6 Bishop g5 anyway and now
the move F for an attempt to somehow get
something going with this tactic Bishop
takes Bishop taste would check hitting
the rope King takes and now rook ef-1
you're pitting the bishop you're
preparing the move g3 you're back in
business
until rook e1 check appears on the board
and ker-splat the queen is pin cannot
capture so you only can move your rook
away and allow your queen to go from the
board and now is all she wrote after
this move now big advantage here for me
you had a queen sitting on the board
which is huge already a big deal and
we're gonna get grandmasters arena crush
on the in the line in a second King g8
you would think this was over until
after g4 she played Queen sexy for there
was no reason to open the file to see
Bishop g7 suddenly laying on the board
and wait a minute what's going on King
takes rook g1 and after just a few moves
suddenly night at five rook F 896 she
was just down massive material now only
a pawn down the mooc the game takes on
another 50 moves so not so easy White
had drawing chances to be sure but it
did not work out I mean it must have
given all of Julian's fans heart
palpitations to see the position be what
it was and end up here but it was not
enough as the Women's World Champion
survived what wasn't her best game to be
sure of the tournament and ended up
moving on but we do have a guest all the
way from Brooklyn and you know a fellow
Brooklynite when you see one and dear
friend to the club and is it seven-time
US Women's Champion working on number
eight soon Grandmaster Irina crush hey
Irina
hey welcome to the show Irina thank you
I
tell which game you were talking about
Maurice without any of the players names
you've also you've still been following
the Women's World Championship well yeah
yeah of course I spent my morning
looking at the games and yeah I wasn't
sure because you know sometimes when
somebody gets eliminated from the
tournament they're like forget about
that tournament let's look at everything
else but what do you think so far who is
your favorite which which of these eight
remaining well not eight but which of
these remaining women do you think are
gonna win the title well I think first
of all you know two of the matches are
going to tie breaks tomorrow and today
yeah today was a big day there was a
really interesting game abdoumaliq
versus Maryam was a joke and I think I
think I'm due Malik is really gonna be
haunted by her 34th move because you
know she was up in exchange in a pretty
normal looking end game we're definitely
black at compensation but it didn't seem
necessary to lose that and then she had
a simple kind of like to move
calculation to make and move 34 which
would just like give back the exchange
but get back and get into the endgame
was like night versus Bishop that was
pretty much gonna be impossible for
black to and I even I think from a
practical point of view would have been
better for a Abdul Malik and she missed
that she kind of she blundered instead
and went on to lose with the white
pieces so I would I would give Maria
Musa took the advantage in the in the
tiebreaks I mean she's been in this
position before and I think she'll work
her magic again and I would probably
give the advantage to Ana Musa to Gaul
so in the in the tie breaks tomorrow
versus um because 10 you there max has
been really even in these two games but
I feel like where they agreed to a draw
today I guess white made a move and
offered a draw and was accepted but
looks like black could have pressed on
with no risk
she actually were just gonna be a little
bit better in that end game and I feel
like you know you got to do everything
you can squeeze out everything you can
if the position allows it so I'm not
sure sure she had more time also and
like a little bit of a better end game
so you sound like you're ducking the
question though she's the question was
who do you think
what people are not even guaranteed to
advance first I'm talking about what you
know what we're gonna see the Faro but I
mean if if those those two advance and
then we have lag no and jus yeah I think
I think probably actually I'm not sure
how the final round pairings would work
out but I guess
Samiha logical final would be like jus
versus Anna Musa Chuck and Irina you
just got back from countryman C's to
yourself you won your first match in a
thrilling a tie-break victory over in a
gamma Kappa anko where you actually just
went 2-0 and then you played against you
and Jun in round 2 tell us a little bit
about Conti montesque what's it like
there and what was your experience in
the two matches you played yeah well me
my favorite part of being there was
definitely playing chess you know I
enjoyed that more than I enjoyed you
know dressing up and like very warm
clothes to just be able to go outside
without freezing it's a very cold place
although apparently this season was a
lot warmer than it was six years ago
when we had like minus 20 temperatures
and this was a lot more bearable it
snowed a few times I think it was gonna
snow a lot more when I left well what
else can I tell you I enjoyed I enjoy
the nice restaurant I found by the
playing hall it was a gorge in place
that I ate in like every single day
after the game finished and what else do
want to know about well Irena you won
your first match but with the way the
pairings structure worked once you got
through your first match against calf
and ankle on tiebreak you had to play
the number one seed and she had had a
day off so how'd you feel about that
like looking at the pairings chart were
you kind of like man I wish my reading
were a little different like either
lower or higher so I didn't have this
like gauntlet around - yeah it's
interesting I definitely didn't have
that that feeling like of like oh no
like Who am I facing in round 2 I was I
was looking forward to that because I
kind of feel like at this point um you
know you're gonna have to face these
players at some point in the competition
anyway and whether you go home and
around 2 or 3 or even 4 just doesn't
make any difference at all
you know all right like for me you know
like yeah it's uh so I didn't mind
facing her in round two I thought it was
actually a great opportunity you know
it's not that easy to get a match
against the the women's world champion
even if it's just a two-game match so I
was pretty happy about that um even
though it sent me home
kind of early I would have liked to play
a few more a few more games but it was
it was a good opportunity and my games
were you know pretty close I would say I
mean I lost the first game and yeah well
that you just nurse this end game edge
against you I just wished like you would
had a day of rest like she did
is that very significant in these
matches do you give the edge that the
people who win in the classical portion
so they don't have so they actually get
a day to prepare and rath well I think
it was probably good for her you know
she was she seems to be kind of sick you
know she was coughing all the time
during our games so I do think you know
any days off that she could get would be
good for her and yeah I think she's the
only player so far who has not had to
play any tiebreaks right I was one thing
I noticed yeah out of all the people
left in the field she's the only one who
managed to get through in all the
regular limit games isn't it a big
advantage I mean I mean it's helpful the
days off days off were really good
because the tiebreak days are very
intense you know it's basically like
everything your life is packed into
those two games you know you got to
prepare for white for black for what
what they might play in wrap it in blitz
as opposed to what they might play in
regular time controls so from that point
of view it's a very very intense day
it's not like you just stroll in and
play a couple of rapid games like I will
tonight at the Marshall chess club arena
there's there's some talk given for
example the luxurious pace that the men
play at and also the fact that Joe
engine only gets to be champion for
about a few months about whether or not
this system is fair and I may be
extremely exciting of course 64 players
also get a chance to play for the title
but is there any talk among the women
that it's the the guys get basically to
do this kind of candidates followed by
a match also two years to be able to
enjoy the title versus the situation
that it seems is in the women's
tournament which it just seems like it's
a little bit chaotic it could be a match
it could be a knockout and it's always a
compressed period yeah you know Morgan I
want to just remind you like um there's
only a little bit more than ten years
ago I think in 2006 when the we had the
same Women's World Championship knockout
tournament we had to play Tigra games on
the day of the second game so you were
playing late into the night and then the
next morning you just have to go and
play you know match number two or
whatever so I mean and that was
something that was something the men
didn't have they had those days off
before the tie breaks which of course
makes sense and the women were playing
them after regular - regular classical
games up and like late into the night so
that was seemed a lot worse I mean they
they did fix that after that
championship in 2006 so that we we have
a special day for tiebreaks you know I
don't think that anyone is unhappy that
things are moving to a candidate system
like the guys have I think that makes a
lot of sense I'm speaking of the guys
what's your take on Tara wanna Carl to
him who's like a win what's the exact
score gonna be who do you want to win
the predictions but you know I mean I
definitely hope for or just a the best
player to win you know and of course
since Fabi is representing the u.s. you
know I'm more I'm more leaning towards
him but not because I don't like Magnus
in any way I'm actually a big Magnus fan
as well and I think these is just a
great match and I hope chest wins oh
that's sweet that's a good way to put it
what do you think of the match so far I
assume you've been following the games
yeah I mean I really liked Game one you
know and I'm so so happy that Carlsen is
playing the Sicilian I mean I think that
that just makes me really happy to see
these kinds of openings I mean I'm
Sicilian player myself and for him to
start with the match with a Sicilian
that was great and I really liked the
way he played that game I mean I thought
I'm just a great game by him and it was
really just like you know it was a too
bad for him that he couldn't convert
that but obviously a good save from five
and then since then it's been you know
more or less I close fight
and what Sicilian do you believe that
Magnus is gonna uncork if Bobby goes for
d4 or hath hasn't been gettin a lot from
the Bishop b5 so oh I guess my my guess
would be they the especially cope now
that I was also wondering about that
right but I mean he's starting with
knight c6 so the only thing that the top
players really would use that move order
for is the sveshnikov and that's
something animal was a choucas going to
you know seems to be serving or well so
yeah I'm thinking maybe that that's his
idea we were thinking that maybe he was
trying to play your favor or for Knight
Sicilian and just doesn't mind playing
against 96 even thinks those lines after
Bishop b5 are good for him so it's kind
of like a little a little fake out
that's true that it's definitely that's
a possibility as well and I can say you
know after studying the classical
Sicilian a lot for my first match
against Tina got Panang KO that there
are some interesting lines there you
know the rouser black is a big choice
right it's you know white kinda has to
go for the rouser and then like so many
different system that black is the one
choosing so maybe he's got something
there
well it's good to have you back with us
arena I just wanted to say that to get
to Conte it's actually not that easy how
did you travel by the way did you go
through Moscow or could you go out take
another indirect flight no yeah I think
you basically have to go through Moscow
I think all the players are going
through Moscow was a little unfortunate
because for people coming from New York
you had it like a 12 hour layover in the
airport and there was just unavoidable
it wasn't like you know there were more
there were better options and was just
like that was the only one so I had to
spend 12 hours this was basically like
two days of traveling and that was hard
it's um
I've noticed that that Han sea has been
the hardest place for me to get adjusted
to in terms of time so I did get there
early but the beginning is just very
miserable you know where you don't know
what time of day it is you're sleeping
during the day or wake at night there's
no sunlight so your body has no real
idea
you know I basically got started to feel
fine after I played my first game so
that I was into their schedule and you
know then it was fine
sounds like the Olympic team is gonna
have to show up a week early when you
guys go to play in a couple of years
there well you know it might be better
in the summer though because it's gonna
be in the summer because like I think
the lack of Sun sunshine is really a big
factor because even when you're awake it
feels like it's night you're always
tired you know you just like when it's
when it's bright it's just gray you know
and uh you're I think it took me like
five days until I saw the actual Sun
they're not with great what a challenge
for the ladies though I mean the ladies
have to play all the ladies who are
remaining it is getting even less and
less light as the the winter proceeds
plus the cold weather as well the
inclement conditions doesn't sound like
fun times for a woman's world
championship well fun of you in the
crown snow it's really beautiful I don't
want to say that it's all bad because
yeah you know if it's only like zero
degrees it's pretty comfortable and the
organization is very good yeah I wanted
to mention that that the playing hall
it's a great venue I personally really
like it they give us like food and
snacks throughout the game constantly
refreshed they're you know giving us
obviously transportation back and forth
you have people who greet us they'll
take our coats girls working there are
very friendly so I think the
organization is on a very very good
level yeah I've noticed they've got
great tweets actually at uber a chat so
if you want to continue to follow that
tournament not only following the games
you get a lot of color interviews polls
via their Twitter feed thank you so much
Irina
for joining us that the Grandmaster
Irina cross 7 time
well arena arena arena just before we go
we run game for the last move was King
g2 sweetheart give me your insights into
this position who stands better and why
and what's your prediction you're
talking about the game right yeah the
last move was King G 1 2 G 2 by white
and it's
this ending of two rooks now I just
pulled it up on chest balm and yeah I
mean it looks pretty even to me I mean
White's pawn is on a dark square I'm
before that is obviously the key factor
here Black's rooks are on the open files
so I don't really see white winning this
unless he at least gets like a king to
f5 which is unlikely the King f3g for f5
John what are you saying likely III
could see a direct path
yeah but I'm black well you know either
move the King up or play h5 maybe King
just g7 g6 actually oh yeah I think
he'll try to stop that from happening
striking with an f5 I would be you know
a little bit more concerned so you
reckon a draws in the is in the is the
most probable yeah I think it's the most
probable yeah I just have to say I love
the opening choices of this match I mean
seeing some variety like the English
opening the Sicilian you know d4 for
Magnus I think yeah the opening choice
I'm pretty pretty happy about very good
thank you Eva thank you so much for
joining English guys all right take care
Maurice we have a couple more moves we
do have after rook d1 rook d8 the
immediate rugby one to c1 by the way was
played by Magnus right the issue of
keeping rips on the board you know we
talked about which pieces you keep on on
the chessboard and you have to have a
real feel for that intuition this rookie
d1 Bishop f8 85 85 King g2 and then rook
d8 and no we keep keep more pieces on
right keep them on and the question of
pressurizing a position you're the point
that arena made about somehow getting
the king so you can attack this pawn
this pawn is the other weak pawn in
blacks position that white has actual
clear access to but how do you
pressurize it remember you have a bishop
a monochromatic piece it can't change
colors so it can't this Bishop can't
suddenly attack this e6 pawn it's not
going to happen
King is gonna find a very difficult to
come over and help attack the c6 pawn so
how do you pressurize the position how
do you make any other other how do you
tie black down how do you make black
feel like I'm on the defensive
you'd have to double on this pawned the
two rooks
and hope that black both blacks rooks
are suffering on that square as well
because otherwise black will just ignore
it and hit on your beep on and say you
have to defend that while you can have
my c6 pawn while I win your B pawn so
this is gonna be White's only chances
somehow get this play going and then at
some point also pay attention to this
King side as well so we're looking at a
long slow play build up that has been
characteristic of this game so far where
does the white king go how does the the
King side
pawn structure suit itself Magnus will
be inspecting every possibility of
construction of his pawns going up the
board f4 of course is the natural one
but looking at g4 and h5 and seeing what
are the niceties here of constraining
this side once the liquidation happens
on this side as well still a long game
ahead I would say it looks like they
could have just accepted wrong or more
likely Magnus is thinking we're gonna be
here a few hours you know and you gotta
have relax I want to see what this
position is all about especially for
Magnus in positions where he doesn't
think he can lose he will just keep
playing playing playing playing playing
absolutely and there is one idea that I
do find attractive for Magnus let's say
in this position King g7 that that's a
really good start that is actually what
was played excellent King f3 so the idea
here is not necessarily to go King g4 I
fought f5 as much as it is I really want
to provoke the move h5 if we could just
put the move h5 on the board for a
second then I want to play h4 and I
remember this as a gift really from bent
Larsen I just didn't appreciate how good
the move h4 was in that specific
position because the idea is to play g4
and to get it passed
a past h-bond and this could be
potentially where white could use his
majority somehow if you could get in the
move g4 provoked a capture yeah g4
provoke a capture now I don't know rook
a to Bishop rook a to Bishop to D to e
one and now we see that if white could
play h5 check in King H King f5 he's in
there with a shout he's getting some
initiative and this is what I think
that'd be just simply has to avoid he
can't allow this past h4 pawn right and
Magnus back here after King to g7 did
play the move Bishop to e1 attacking the
policy said pressure on c6 forcing a
rook to defend that pawn for the moment
right you see the reason why he took his
rook off the open file which
traditionally people would say well
that's the open file why would you give
it to a rook rook belong and open files
yes but semi open files can also be just
as sweet if not sweeter because semi
open file there's a pawn remaining right
if it's not yours that is then all the
better and if it's backwards this one is
then even more so sweet so he's got the
semi open far with a weakness and a
backward pawn the move c5 doesn't look
like it's coming with any kind of effect
anytime soon so black will have to use a
rook to defend that and that's what
we're talking about the potential of
doubling on this pawn and maybe forcing
black to defend twice so that will start
to tie black's pieces down and then
white will look for that energy on the
other side as well so this position is
not just drawn right that is clear white
Magnus's endgame virtuosity will be on
full display as he looks now to see if
he can milk this position for all it's
worth a little bit Thank You Maurice and
Jennifer this is actually quite unique
we have a collar but I can't ever
remember st. Louis is calling say
welcome to the show from st. Louis let
us know your name and your question hi
my name is Jim hi welcome to our show
yeah my question is so what do you guys
think that either one of the competitors
are gonna have to do to break this
string of draws maybe a novelty opening
or I mean what do you think we're gonna
see you know to get to break this
pattern of draw right well thank you for
the question I remember one particular
World Championship match that was taking
place in New York City in the Twin
Towers and it was between Gary Kasparov
and Vishy Anand and help me out here
Maurice I think it was eight consecutive
draw that is correct it's a record never
never been seen at the beginning of a
match they're having consecutive draws
inside of a match that have been longer
famously Kasparov Karpov of 1985 when
they had 17 straight 1984 actually the
right the 80 4584 slash 85 because the
match took months right 648 games in
fact but they had 17 straight draws in
the middle of the match now that is a
serious record but to start a match
eight straight draws was this one in
1995 Kasparov unknown that was played in
New York in you know 1995 as I said
seven straight draws in Magnus's last
match was the second number to start a
match that is him against car yeah Keon
in New York also in New York you know my
hometown is supposed to be a bit more
contentious than that but it looks like
15 straight draws to begin a match a
little bit limp
wet noodle ish but it's hard to break
through in the beginning very hard and
it's I don't think you have to do
anything turns of the Karla's question
but keep playing chess keep playing good
moves because let me tell you you might
want to win but you sure as heck don't
wanna lose right and so you don't want
to do something funky and all of a
sudden it's like oh I just lost so
they're gonna just keep looking for
their chances looking to milk
opportunities and see if something
arises out of the games they've got
plenty of arrows in that quilt and
they're gonna say let's just keep
shooting and see if the guy misses
something in lanza mark but no reason to
go
to try to win that first game by the way
the game that uh non won finally
against tomorrow that was game nine he
didn't do anything spectacular just kept
playing another and putting a Sicilian
got in this idea on the queenside with B
five squeeze Garry and that was all that
she wrote winning that game Gary came
right back with a dragon and blew him
off the board and then went on and just
started winning a lot of games sometimes
it just takes a game for it to get going
well that was one of the things I wanted
to say about that match especially
because I remember it so vividly these
eight draws but then once there was a
win it was like a dam burst and then
winning became easy so at a certain
moment we call for Gary well and then
you feel like once one player wins what
do you think of Rex's prediction of
three decisive games do you think that's
about right that's very fair actually
yeah I do see that as a way as a pathway
to a fab EVIC turi so we're do one if
there's gonna be three and there's only
twelve everything that game four was
game four yeah well it's not game four
since I read the game five then
automatically I win price are right
right that's right oddly close system
that is price is right I'll be closest
to the answer no matter what you guys
will be left at a dust five or over and
I get the win hey no I think it's like
the world if it revolves around its
closer to three again the world but I
don't think it's gonna be all girls do
know so I it was actually quite strange
Tony rich and his narrative how happy
was going to win the match began with a
victory from Magnus then he saw
fabbi tying the match up taking the lead
and winning the match so whatever the
narrative I'm kind of with Rex on this
one I do see three victories out of the
twelve games
we should point out that that in the
history of these World Championships
these twelve not gamers we know all the
way back to World War two post-world War
two
we're talking about World Championship
matches that win more than 20 games 24
game managers with a majority or the
norm in the long matches say from bond
vidiq onwards yeah yes the score and I
will get the exact number but the score
for the person who is who is ahead at
four at the fourth game or any time
after and I'm talking about in long 24
games which you think would would not
make a difference but the score is
something like 16 - for some number some
ridiculous number that if you're a head
as in favor of the leader the leader
takes a lead at Game four or five or six
or seven something any point after Game
four the score is atrocious for the
person who was behind which doesn't seem
like it should be the case in long
matches especially in short matches you
would anticipate in a 12 game match take
a lead late yeah that sounds right
although that's not necessarily that
true either magnets for example was
behind at game eight of his last match
against Kuryakin and still came back and
won the match so it's and there's
another match I don't remember which one
it is that was the case as well so it's
not it doesn't seem like it it should be
decisive in the longer matches but it
has been the case that the number is
simply out of this world that the person
who was leading at or after four wins
something like eighty percent of the
time Wow which is incredible well for me
of course it was the 1972 match Bobby
Fischer loses the first game forfeits
Game two so he's down to no wins amazing
Game three with Knight h5 but now I've
already forgotten what was the result of
the fourth game in that match because
I'm thinking that Boris had an the lead
after four games he certainly had a lead
after three things though he was leading
2-1
I mean after three so we'll have
just double-check and here again we have
some of this marvelous archive which has
also been used in the fireside chats
that we've been filming over the most
memorable World Championship matches and
indeed there is Bobby Fischer the great
and look at the hands again I just to
emphasize his bare hands I amazing a
Bobby Fischer but I remember this from
ABC Wide World of Sports he finally had
settled down for for Game one and he's
about to play Knight g8 f6 and watching
how he also so the knight is facing
Boris Spassky but then he's going to
swing the night so that the face is to
say we're talking about on the broadcast
war and because of the way he moved that
night that influenced me in my games to
do the same thing but you know I would
play Knight g8 f6 and put the knight on
the side because I wanted to imitate
Bobby Fischer by the way he did win the
game for was a draw in that match so
sport is Boris led after four yeah
bracelet at the fourth at the fourth
game because of that forfeit though
right because of that forfeit only right
but then Fischer won Game five tied it
up it tied it up won Game six and took
the lead and that's all she wrote
one game eight and ran away ran away Wow
also we should point out some of the
wins were the rules were different
because the champion kept the title in
case of a tie right so many times even
though even though the champion was
behind or the champion took the lead at
that point the champion was able to tie
it up at 1212 in many of the matches
because authentic Smith's law for
example was a tie Karpov Kasparov was a
tie in one of the matches that that's he
had to do that one in Seville so
sometimes you either wall a few times at
least the champion at the edge because
they kept
that title in their pocket if it was a
tie at the end it was a twenty four game
match and it ended in a tie right I also
famously of course Kramnik versus Peter
Lake oh yes also ended in a tie and that
one kept the title in chronics pocket
hoping for this time guys
it can't happen hoping that won't occur
but uh it is going the game is going
under the path that I read a crash
predicted with the king trying to come
to g4 to f5 but of course Fabi well
pleased to meet that idea with King to
g6 and we're gonna leave you actually
Irina had come to talk about the Women's
World Championship underway we're gonna
leave you with a fireside chat about the
first Women's World Championships in
history and the incredible women who
starred them a very amend check the
nine-time world women's champion
champion and Sonya Graf but one of the
most intriguing World Championship
matches of all time was between Vera
manchak and Sonja Graf and this is one
that really could be made into a movie
and I know Jen this is one of your
favorite topics to talk about well
absolutely because the thing about chess
and particularly this Women's World
Championship in 1939 is the way that
chess intersects with the history of the
world and no more time is that statement
more apt than the 1939 Olympiad held in
Buenos Aires in Argentina and this was
both an Olympiad for the open and also a
Women's World Championship but it wasn't
a match it was more like an open
tournament and the best woman would win
so there was very men chick who was
already a seven-time Women's World
Champion
so she was coming in as a heavy favorite
they set sail from Europe in July of
1939 having no idea of course that they
would not be coming back some of them
the war was about to break out in Europe
that's right so the tournaments began in
August in Buenos Aires and actually in
the case of Sonja Graf
who was living in Germany at the time
she was told by Goebbels
the Minister of Nazi propaganda that she
could not play for Germany because she
was so vocal against the Nazi regime
she got stripped of her flag and had to
play under the flag of Liberty she ended
up getting second in the tournament
second to Vera min-shik who just got 18
out of 20 points completely crushed the
field well and she was winning in her
individual game against Vera so she was
ever so close to becoming the women's
world champion and I always think of
that as a bit sad because Sonia was such
an incredible figure when it comes to
her character and you know she was an
author a bon vivant one of the people
who really showed how chess could leave
you this life of adventure right um but
she didn't win the championship Vera men
chick did the very sad thing about very
many she did go back to Europe
unlike Sonja Graf unlike Knight orphe
and she died in the London Blitz in 1944
one of them bombings exactly but Sonja
knew that you know after Goebbels said
that about her it was pretty clear that
she wasn't going anywhere gonna survive
so she stayed in Argentina ended of
immigrating into the United States and
actually won a couple of US women's
championships right um another player
who also ended up staying in Argentina
who's very well known to audiences is
McCallum my door absolutely well in fact
the entire polish team I said we're not
going to go back to Poland and they all
stayed as did many many other European
players saying look you know the
outbreak of war in Europe it's just not
safe and their allotment mostly Jewish
there's no question about it and if you
stop and think about it how the heck are
you supposed to get back to Europe
anyway I mean it's not like you're just
gonna catch an international jet flight
you're gonna take a ship and how do you
know the ship's not gonna get blown out
all the bombings that were going on
absolutely the relevance of that also to
the World Championships because you have
Alekhine who's sitting there waiting for
a challenger but nothing can be done
absolutely we can't play his war going
on sure so he
Sandi's sits and he's depressed and he's
waiting around for a challenger all
those years while the war is going on
exactly and at the very end when the war
finally stops he gets a bid that says
he's gonna be chat he can finally play
again and then he dies in his hotel room
exactly and so the war had such an
impact on chess and the history of the
World Chess Championship and not just
the men's as you mentioned with ala Kane
but also the ladies so in the case the
vote we know what they did to solve the
world championship now we have a vacant
title what did they do in the case of
the ladies it wasn't always match play
it was tournament place did they just
continue the tournament well the next
world Women's World Championship if I
recall correctly was be cold and rude
anko those are Soviet at the time now
yes but with with Vera manchak dying in
1944 I mean what a tremendous loss for
the chess world you know Vera men shake
was way ahead of her time she was the
first woman that would play against the
top men of her day yeah and in fact
there was famously a very mentok Club
that's right which was supposed to be
for men who there was a very elite group
of names in that club wasn't there
exactly that you wanted to join but they
almost took it seemed like there was a
lot of a camaraderie yes she was a
really nice person and it's just
devastating to see about we really could
add even more from these players you
know more stories more games and I think
that's what's so amazing about chess
history how it's an art that we can look
at the games and it also intersects with
history itself and for children
especially that can you know teach you
about these wars World War 2 had a
massive impact in the chess world but
particularly in women's chess
killing this grand figure of chess who
was the first woman to compete on the
equal terms with men way ahead of her
time not only did you do really the
judith Polgara of the world and that
exact moment also of course you've
mentioned the loss of alexander alekhine
but there were many grandmasters that
simply died by hunger or disease
starvation I mean these two world wars
devastated Europe and
stated the chess world indeed and it led
to a rethink of how the World
Championships would be run from that
moment on the events of fidei taking
over as an international body and the
age really of the private World
Championships ended right there with the
war closed a very important point in
chess history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to carlson Cara
Juana where we are deadlocked going into
came for one and a half points for the
Norwegian Iranian champ and one and a
half points for the first American
challenger to contest the undisputed
title since Bobby Fischer
Fabiano marijuana now in this game are
we also deadlocked
we certainly do appear to be that's the
case essentially five versus five two
rooks apiece materials dead even black
skin you might say is actually a little
bit more active than whites King that's
not a salient factor usually in these
endings is all about passed pawns
neither side has passed pawn at the
moment there is a way for black to try
to create a passed pawn we see 65 I'm
thinking after King ISA ISA our the
position is simply so balanced that a
draw is really really highly probable at
this point Jennifer this there's just
not enough I don't know but no I do I do
believe that we'll probably see
something in the near future like a move
like rook c1 we're just a lot of trades
end up getting happening and you know
it's funny the first two games featured
rook endings where both sides enjoyed
the advantage of a pawn that wasn't
meaningful so keep going if if black
were to where does black play here and
now if you go after the pawn with rook
age sake then probably something like
check and I'll come over here return the
favor yeah you attacked my pawn I'll
kind of attack your pawn and just I I
just see a lot of a lot of pawns leaving
the board may be exactly by the way here
at this point I could Lu no it doesn't
want to do it I could
King d7 as well and now with King III
I'll check you I want I want you to
deter yeah so after King you to rook be
to check if I really want to make
progress at some point I'm gonna have to
play like King d3 me right but now I
really am you or you probably okay so
this leads nowhere
exactly it's a Cohen accurately the one
we were gonna play 52 again um I'm not
sure I thought I thought that there was
going to be a massive how'd he say grab
your back yeah the the cleaner lady was
gonna appear on stage or something like
like that we're all of these pawns get
vacuumed off the board and I'm just
suggesting this rook ending I think I
could have probably played a little bit
more precision here you always have to
check the pawn endgame you always want
to check on it game but yeah that
shouldn't that looks but it does feel
like this type of variation where so
many pieces get just swapped off is
always in the works Maurice I just don't
see how Magnus is gonna squeeze I mean
he's notorious for squeezing and getting
something but I just don't see anything
here for him
yeah there's no soft cotton here to
squeeze this yeah head of simply a draw
we talked about this when you have
high-level players this level you're
gonna see a lot of work component games
Ryan you're talking about 2800 players
here you're gonna see a lot of end games
even if down upon the person is gonna
bail they're gonna bail into something
that is drawable within the drawing
range the defensive prowess of today's
players is fantastic it's just simply
fantastic they've seen the history of
chess they've got all of that to help
them and then there's this thing called
the computer that has shown them even
more so in the old days a player might
get a disadvantage and just get blown
off the board or see the pressure just
build and build and build the modern
players are incredible at putting up
serious defenses fortresses even they
are able to show that chess is
very very close to a draw so you have to
catch them with something something
special has to happen or a guy has an
off day makes a bad mistake or just play
perfect chess all the way through even
when you have an event you still have to
play perfect chess all the way through
because they're gonna compete and
compete against you move after move we
saw that first game Carlson had his
chance you know three draws in a row
especially with two whites he's got to
be feeling like what's up I mean this is
having shades of his match against car
yeah kid as the it goes more and more
and he'll have black again the next game
so maybe even five draws is the best you
can hope for so that's the kind of thing
we're gonna see you this a lot and the
tension is just going to keep building
and building in the building I know that
caller sounded real frustrated yeah yeah
where's it gonna be a win up in here
right this is building this is building
and building the tensions rising and
right yeah it's just getting scarier and
scarier because the moment you feel like
man if I lose a game I am going down no
it's not historically that's not been
the case you can still make that
comeback as Magnus Schroeder in this
last match but that's the fielding
you're gonna have you get the feeling
like that about these two they're such
high-level players that if the win
happens late it's probably the match
okay that's that's how I'm starting to
feel but we're not there yet we're still
only a game four I think if you see the
win the first one happened in the last
third of the match it's gonna be deadly
man the net in the second third you
could probably make a comeback still a
couple of non chess factors because you
talked about how the players are number
one and number two and they're so close
they're they're their chess skill levels
are extraordinarily high when you get
into a match situation like this where
you are having the series of draws this
kind of a sense of frustration that you
can't break through we also start
talking about nerves one of the things
I've been seeing and it's not been a
good thing in fab YZ Ches in the last
year too time trouble has been begin to
creep into his play more and more I've
seen him getting into
trouble really using a lot of his clock
and that's usually a bad sign it means
that he's double-checking everything
he's just you know he wants to be really
really sure and as the tension of the
match builds up because nobody's making
a breakthrough nerves and the use of the
clock could become a factor and again
it's non chess it's not you know chess
understanding its match play it's
it's just just critical critical moments
critical moment in a competition whether
it's even was a tournament it could be
round seven round nine when that starts
to happen then it starts to really
affect you and I think that's a very
good point because I think as far as
Magnus is concerned the more attention
the better the more critical the better
he has shown himself to be an incredible
incredibly cool competitor and he
delivers when he needs to again we can
go to the last match he lost the car car
yakin in game eight and was able to
still come back win a game to shut
things down after that and then go to
the tiebreak and then dominate so that
is something we just don't know as far
as fabi's concern and history has shown
that those situations don't necessarily
favor him it's not clear-cut we're not
saying that isn't that it's not gonna be
good for him but it's just not clear-cut
especially in rapid and blitz where it's
been very clear with the number one
player on the planet is so that's an
important point the more the the match
goes that in Carlson's favor he doesn't
have to take too many chances in order
to get something from these positions
right now to the position itself
Maurice we've just seen this move Bishop
e7 to d6 as a saved by Fabio fabbi and
he's basically saying well I'm in no
hurry to try to force anything with c-65
or for that matter
f7 f5 is there anything white can do
here I just I'm looking I'm looking I'm
looking I mean does the chess engine
have any ideas it really feels dead oh
it's definitely dead this position and
the engine gives the move H for which
backward or pawn I know you would not
appreciate a move like that one okay not
my first choice for sure to be sure but
not because there's anything in the
position next one's gonna be Bishop eat
one after Bishop e7 for example Bishop
to e1 and no real progress just a flat
move with nothing much to do we could
start making moves here over and
over and over just for fun yeah like you
we can start analyzing what have we try
this what if we try that what have we
tried that what we'll get at is this is
drunk
that's what's gonna happen so you can
experiment as much as you want and flow
through all kinds of this is drawn now
can may be a mistake and lose the game
of course of course
sure but from a technical standpoint you
it we'd have to induce the blunder we'd
have to make the blunder on purpose
to say oh now suddenly somebody's
winning because this one here is way to
equal right I feel that if there was
some edge in the position it was before
the move f6 f6 f5 was was played once
that that trade got played it seemed
that the problems were over Jennifer we
have a caller that's right from North
Carolina and let us know your name and
question hi my name is Charles Roberson
hi Charles
I have two pieces of information about
some conversations yesterday okay the
first one was pertaining to something an
argument a debate y'all were having and
Jennifer was right and the guys were
wrong and the second one was about
something Yaser said pertaining to
asserting your will in chess back to the
first one it was back up moves the
Maurice specifically was saying it's
hardest it was easy to see easy to see
back up moves the Jennifer was feeling
not so easy for some people here and I
see lots and lots of beginners that
believe that the most aggressive person
wins so you should never make backup
moves so they have found it very very
hard to see those and I think that
conversation came up yesterday during
the spot where the lack plays was a
eight which was yeah and I thought that
was an obvious move to you but Jennifer
was right she said that some people find
it very hard to see back up news
so can you use olive and nobody else can
well no 100% no at Jennifer was right
and the reality was let's just get that
in a loop over over let's get that on a
gif file but post-game Abbey was the
first to say that has moved the ship DC
Bishop d2 was a mistake and he had
missed the retreating move rook on a 5-2
a8 which ended his advantage
not Bishop Bishop rook takes a fight he
just got there and he said oh I can make
the same position and I could just play
Bishop d2 and accelerate rook a one
Queen eight one position I was trying to
a tree at least that was the comments I
read about so Fabi missed it but our
caller saw it so that's just an example
of how you know being well first of all
you don't have to pick one move when
you're when you're watching that's why
kibitzers tend to see so much because
they were able to look at all the
different possibilities whereas when
you're sitting there right you're even
in the very best player in the world has
to pick one move and they may have a
tunnel vision yeah I mean certainly in
my case I mean oftentimes I see a
position I and I said oh I really really
strategically I want to get my knight
into the center of the board or the game
is over we have our fourth draw of the
Karlsson Cara wanna match as Carlson was
not able to make headway with the white
pieces and this somewhat promising
reverse dragon that Bobby Bobby Bobby
deftly equalized so you know achievement
for Bobby again I would say yes no no
question about it I'd if I was Magnus I
would love to repeat this this game
position there was a number of hesitant
moves and fretted away the advantage but
the point was fabbi held very
comfortably I mean again we've talked
about it the for 500 years the strategy
of World Championship matches
been very simple 500 yeah longer you put
pressure on the guy with white you hold
with black well it seems to me that
white hasn't put any pressure on the
black player whatsoever and that it
almost feels like in this match white
doesn't have any advantage well I'm not
sure I think our caller had another
point oh yeah sorry well as we as our
caller was talking when the match result
so North Carolina still on the line
there was two questions he was just
saying that you were right oh then he
said something about my comment - so you
were right - oh I'm not sure about that
part only bet you had been right about
the retreating move and that amateurs
have this fear that if they play
passively they're going to lose one so
they have to play aggressively right and
not to retreat their pieces by the way I
didn't say that doesn't that's not the
case that wasn't yes exactly of course
retreating moves are I know why not I
made a whole DVD on this in fact and one
of them is what GM's find difficult to
see how a players fight never that's the
are retreating moves not just retreating
moves of course there are other moves as
well that people find difficult to see
you for example moves that occur on
squares where pawns guard that Square
sometimes you just be completely blind
to it discovered checks some something
is difficult to see walking into a
discovery a lot of people over a
discovered attacks and retreating moves
so yes I completely agreed with that I
was talking about that exact position
and I have to say I am in fact stunned
that in that situation Fabi thought
Roque was force um that that just shows
you again that blind spot is one of the
categories that strong players miss and
that one was one of them and Fabi to
miss it pretty surprising where are you
we're all human I was just looking at
this particular rook ending that's right
even Maurice is wrong sometimes that's
the moral of the story
we've all been there otherwise we would
win all of our games yeah so a
comfortable easy hold I would say for
fabbi very very nice
I thought seriously right about here
these parts I would call this a hesitant
or soft move
I thought III was hesitant
these last three moves for me is where I
think Magnus really lost whatever lion's
share if there's any share of advantage
I do like white but I think he had to
get in b5 really early and we were
looking at a possible line of play that
may have been captures captures a5 that
put Magnus off
I like White's position that's all I can
really say and when Magnus didn't go for
the idea of efore followed by d4 when he
did not play in this way but instead
played for e3 then already at this point
I thought that fabbi
they did that the draw was I'm gonna say
inevitable you know it's funny yes you
showing that position with the one would
be 5 early or actually multiple
positions
I find it it's something really
interesting about strength and ability
because a player is a stronger player as
Magnus is clearly stronger than any of
us you've been top 10 because he's
stronger doesn't mean that he's stronger
than you in all positions absolutely
right
like any position you put in front of
Magnus he's gonna play better than any
position you put in front of ya so Sarah
absolutely none because people
specialize in certain things and we know
for example that English was your bread
and butter
that's so you're gonna be like a fish in
in the right pond right the English
right great we're gonna if we're gonna
only play English is this whole
tournament
this whole match
I'm gonna be a 2804 sure right if you're
gonna switch up and play a variety of
openings and they're really comfortable
over there we got away that for some
Sicilians I've never played that what is
that about right
caro-kann okay see Ron is back in
business so depends on the situation so
for you
you saw the you've you've sat over these
positions for decades literally and you
see all the new ones you feel exactly
you should do this you should try this
one this one no that's not gonna work
that's garbage oh yeah I know you think
that's unclear but this we're gonna
build with this one oh the Knights off
the board Maurice but you know what I've
seen Bob Vinick do blah blah blah blah
blah cause this is what I live for right
so look at some magnets and magnets of
course knows a copious amount of stuff
it's unreal how much stuff he knows you
can quote so many circumstances but it
doesn't mean that every single position
is going to feel as finely as everybody
else who specializes in that specific
place exactly and so I'm looking at you
just throw moves out and say now this
idea what I want this idea and Magnus
hesitating a little bit in that
situation may have cost him may have
cost him the game yeah are these
opportunities to really build what will
they give a more advantageous position
well you brought up something just
absolutely phenomenal in 1970s when I
started playing chess I mean the top top
grandmasters were specialists they
played efore exclusively that was it
they played d4 exclusively that was it
they played c4 exclusively that was it
and one of the things that I just find
absolutely extraordinary about the elite
the top ten players today is their
ambidextrous they can punch with either
hand they can go sorry they got more
than anything everything white and with
black efore d4 c4 and it's like they're
masters of all trades that even so you
know somebody like Magnus who knows just
as you said such copious amounts of
middle games and end games doesn't mean
that they're going to be absolute
absolute specialists this game today
Magnus I'm sure felt that he had an edge
but then he didn't play it like just
absolutely perfectly and it would have
required really really great play to get
some significant advantage and from you
know fab ease point of view he got an
easy position and he held it and this is
a real confidence builder that's well
and I think no I can only think about it
in that way but I'm looking at it it
reminds me of kromm League statement
yesterday ok about form and this this
point he made he said when fabi's in
great form you can beat anybody any
including magnetism just run right
through him right run right through
anyone right not necessarily Magnus but
the Magnus is felt fabi's fire before
sure but if Magnus is not on great form
he's still gonna be basically Magnus
right basically and basically Magnus is
20 or 50 I mean right so it's basically
Magnus and and Fabi could be like a 2953
like a machine so the issue is it looks
to me right now that neither one of them
is informed at the moment like
something's gonna have to click after
that first game it looked like that uh
look like Magnus was playing like a
superstar then didn't seal the deal
since then they've both looked a little
bit like the moment I don't know it's
the moment I don't know if it's the
opponent I don't know what's going on
but right now we're not seeing them play
incisive Rock'em Sock'em pure chess
moves that's not happening right now and
dus using the time because it because
that you're talking about yessir has a
lot to do with timing like I should play
b5 now don't wait around because if you
wait around guys going to consolidate
really fast and then it's gonna be easy
so timing is a big issue as well
and when you're in form you just hit the
right notes all the time hit it now
let's do it right now nope no wait and
that is not there yet for both these
players or also they're both they're
playing each other and they're both so
strong that their defensive skills are
even higher
so that obviously factors it but we do
have a special guest on the line Fred
white skin author of many books
including of course searching for bobby
fisher' which was later a major movie
about his son Josh welcome to the show
Fred it's so great to have you nice to
speak to you Jennifer how you doing oh
we're doing great you're watching this
phenomenal match we're just getting the
right graphic up there in a second I'm
I'm with the Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
a good friend of yours as well as a
grandma its radar on are you doing man
this is a real police is a buddy of mine
for 20 years yeah we forget them after a
couple of decades past right Fred
you know I've been watching the
commentary and really enjoying it
thank you appreciate it and I remember I
haven't seen in years welcome man you
look great
how do you think Oh young man I don't
know but I remember you as curly-haired
what happened for ya yeah really really
curly locks I do just like you so Josh
it's all good great to be on what's your
impression of the this match Fred you
know you've written about Gary Kasparov
of course you wrote about the scholastic
chess scene in searching for Bobby
Fischer are you on Team Bobby you know
I'll say of course of course I'm some
slot for Bobby but I mean I've always
watched chess in a funny kind of way I
mean I've always watched chest
impressionistic Lee I mean I used to
hang out with Kasparov I was with him
for three or four years almost
inseparably and I watched him play a
million games you know we you know
championship games and and also Speed
games but I never really understood
chest like a chess player I sort of
understood it impressionistic Lee I kind
of kind of could feel the position but
if you asked me to work out the tactics
like you thought you guys do every
minute I couldn't have done it then and
now I'm like a lot of years
so I still find it very exciting to
watch it but III don't understand chess
in the same way that like a strong chess
player does the Freddie
as far as psyche psychologically though
you do have great intuitive powers there
and as you did follow Kasparov in is
particularly his last match and what is
your feeling when you you see these
great players these elite players
playing on that level as a world
I think a world champion met match the
tension of the moment as you've tasted
as you've been up close to someone like
agaricus bar oh well you know spending
the time with Kasparov was really
remarkable because I don't think any
journalist ever had the opportunity to
to be with a World Championship player
in all those practices you know gari
agreed to meet with me at the end of
every game to talk about it and he was
he was you know very accessible
emotionally so when he when he lost the
game he was devastated and didn't mind
articulating it and it was really
amazing being there again I'm being
completely honest you know when I when I
watch it on the screen like this I can't
feel it in the same way that I felt it
when I was there but on the other hand
you know I mean just the idea that a
World Championship match is taking place
and the American has a chance to do it
again after like a gazillion years with
Bobby Fischer throwing that was a part
of your history as well right Bobby
Fischer you remember the time in 72 can
you paint a picture for us how that was
yeah I mean it was just it was just
amazing I mean you know like when you
know when Bobby was playing for the
World Championship yeah I I kind of
discovered chess like you know
gazillions of other Americans I mean I
watched the games I watched Shelby Lyman
and bruce pandolfini on television and
Shelby Lyman was this remarkable
remarkable secure because he had this
ability to make chests accessible to
everybody Grandmaster chess accessible
to everybody even though in a sense he
was creating an illusion he gave us all
the feeling that we could we could
create the kind of same moves at Bobby
Bobby did if we just thought about it
for a while we all kind of got sucked
into the solution that we could do
and I was you know at the head of the
class I mean I kind of believe from
watching the match that I was a terrific
player and you know I started playing
against all my friends and and I won a
few games and I decided I was a good
player and then I started going to one
of the chess clubs and I started playing
against the guy who who was who was
reading the newspaper while I was
playing me and checkmated me with that
that regarding the movement aboard and
that was when I started to have a sense
of my illusion of that chess was
different than the reality presenting
this remarkable way you know I had I had
this kid you know six years old and he
was really good at chess and and by the
time he was six and a half he was
beating me hardly looking at the board
so I kind of like had the second chance
at chess and Josh it was great it's
amazing
Fred and you mentioned the illusion of
feeling like you see more than you do of
course every player now who has access
to a stock to you can get that same
feeling and you mentioned your son Josh
and you know ever since he stopped
playing chess he's just been doing
phenomenally I mean the martial arts and
the the phenomenal book the art of
learning you must be very proud being an
author of so many books yourself that he
wrote that great book himself did you
teach him writing after chaste um you
know Josh and I have always had an
unusual relationship in terms of what
was what we've done together I mean you
know I've just finished this new novel
and you know Joshua had three drafts
that made suggestions and when he writes
things usually puts them past me so
we're kind of like in a way we're kind
of like a team and it's uh it's it's
wonderful and I am of course usually
proud of him maintenance yeah I guess
man you are a lot of you views know this
but when he left chess he went into the
martial arts any what became became a
martial arts world champion is that
amazing right absolutely incredible
especially at that late time I remember
because Josh and I worked together for
so many years as you know Fred in your
living room hanging out playing blitz
against each other and analyzing
variations somebody wanted me to thank
Josh for the chess master series as well
that he put together such a great series
that
learn from Annie also wrote a chess book
as well I know Fred you're working on a
new novel and you're working on movies
tell us about your projects really
quickly yeah this has been a very cool
few years for me I spent about two and a
half years writing a screenplay which I
had never done before and it was it's
called the Rays and it's being cast now
it's a very cool story about about a guy
that creates rays you know a lot of sex
drugs and rock and roll in northern
Massachusetts and it's it's a
complicated love story and what one
aspect of it is very amusing is that a
family member comes to this rave a guy
about my age comes to this rave who's
ever been to a rave before and and he
and we get to witness that through his
eyes so it's really kind of amazing and
rumor has it that Al Pacino is going to
play that part which would be really
great if it happened oh my god and the
book that's really dear to my heart now
is is it as a new novel I've worked on
to the last year and a half it's called
deep water blues and it tells the story
of that these three old tree old-timers
who set off enter and an old boat for an
island a very very remote island in the
southern Bahamas where with there used
to be like a kind of glamorous resort
where the rich and famous hung out I
mean also the celebrities went there the
rumor has it something very dark and
sinister and terrible happened to this
place and these guys make this trip
which is quite harrowing in this old
boat and they get to this island and
they discover that this this this place
has been morally and ethically destroyed
by a bite by just by a series of events
that are really quite remarkable and I
don't want to kind of give the whole
plot away but it's an exciting story and
and that'll be coming out on May 1st
that's going on ask about the rave
though did you have in order to research
the screenplay they do have to go out to
a lot of raves like parrots are based on
you at all the lead characters a lot
there's a lot of me in the character and
I'll just tell you tell your secret yeah
I went to the rave alright
sexual God lips are sealed
final question for you frame we let you
go you wrote searching for bobby fisher'
phenomenal success a movie that so many
people have seen and loved you or the
book of course and helped with the
screenplay and we see it you're the
picture there certainly a classic and
that boat mortal games was a lot of fun
as well I did read it too and and that
was very insightful into the genius of
Carrie Kasparov in the access that you
talked about what do you feel about this
match what it could do for American
chess will it do what Bobby Fischer did
back in that Cold War era or something
similar well listen you know you know
Maresa I'm a candy guy so so I mean
first of all if Fabiano's would have win
the match it would be great for American
chess but I think it would be an
exaggeration to say it would do for
American chess with Bobby Fischer did
Bobby Fischer was larger than chess and
he was like Muhammad Ali you know he was
like well half Muhammad Ali was not you
know a boxer he was he was like a mythic
he was a mythic cultural institution and
Bobby was like that he was like a
larger-than-life
person having said that if Fabiano won
it would be great for American show well
said well thank you so much Fred we
appreciate it I know you are about to
set off on vacation so thanks for making
the time for us and good luck with all
these great projects will certainly get
folks to get your book and I wanted this
rave movie wow you gotta let us know
what promoted once more in our show
later next year I look forward to it and
listen guys you know I've been watching
you the last 4 days since you went on
your great great team you know you have
great synergy between you I really love
you Brooke yes thank you so much red
means a lot coming from you thanks guys
alright thank you
you know I it was a couple years ago I
was maybe when I was pregnant or just
had Fabi I reread some are searching for
bobby fisher' and wow it's just so
well-written i mean just the the journey
of being a chess dad and the complicated
emotions it's really fascinating I think
for any parent to read it especially as
I'm starting to see yourself pertly
your child partly as an extension of
yourself right um knowing of course
respecting them as an individual but
also seeing yourself and your partner in
them and it's it's really fascinating
just such a great writer obviously you
can find all of his books online and his
son Josh's book the art of learning he's
become such a popular title not only
among chess players or a martial artists
it's very big in the mindset community
it's big in the poker community just any
kind of community where people are
really stressed about getting better at
what they do because it's super super
competitive and they like hit a wall
right that's where like they need a book
like that right well for me especially I
love the searching for bobby fisher'
book because I love the interplay the
relation of father and son and how you
know oftentimes the father's angry with
a little boy the little boys not going
to do what daddy wants and little boys
angry with daddy because daddy doesn't
allow the little boy to do what he wants
or doesn't even understand the kid and
this relationship between father and son
and how chess really brought this
fantastic bonding and then as Fred was
just talking about you know the writings
that both Josh and Heder do and they
trade files so to speak what a cool way
of staying in touch and having this
relationship where you're you're you're
nurturing one another
and and pushing on a it's very
empowering I think that's fantastic
I've seen them over the decades and it's
a fantastic family Bonnie and kaca fret
that is Fred's daughter Josh's sister
just great bonds between them great love
great sharing great conversations
mm-hm I've been very fortunate to be a
part an extent a part of the extended
family if you will dear friends of mine
and one of the great things about Fred
is you hear it just as he speaks the
lyrical simplicity of his words
I mean his words are well chosen and
they're coming off the top of his head
though and he just it's like a dart just
hit the points at the points the points
and his writing style is like that as
well and just really beautiful character
wonderful now let's refresh ourselves
four games well I got a I got a three
ball we've got maurices is flying out
tonight eat Maurice yeah that's right
again he's going on of a Trevor Noah
show I'm the Daily Show with Trevor Noah
Trevor Noah yeah that's like super
exciting Maurice there it is
tell us about that who's going on the
show with Trevor
you know he made fun of chess let me let
you know here's when when it was the
Daily Show with Jon Stewart he came on
and knocked chess and riot was it was a
good skit I gotta say you guys can look
it up but I'm gonna have to watch this
chops a little bit it's not that we're
gonna have a little fun and of course
I'm sure he's got stuff prepared for me
so hopefully you know I'm on my a-game
to deal with whatever he's got coming
but it's great for chess we're gonna
talk about the world chess championship
so you know we got four draws he's
probably gonna pound me down about the
drawers see what happens whatever it is
it's great to get more and more
publicity for concisely on late night
television having fun with it so it'll
be good I'm flying out tonight out of
st. Louis the show is taping tomorrow
then I've got to figure out my way
bathroom you're right to get here I
don't know if I'm gonna make it exactly
in time for the start of this show we'll
see if I could pull that off hopefully
planes go well and weather is alright
we'll see but that's the aim all right
well hey Maurice have a great time in
New York with Trevor Noah and I can't
wait to see what round five brings I
mean this is this is it this is where
Magnus has to hit because he's got a
couple of whites in a row all right of
course
Fabi gets white the next game but then
Magnus will have two whites in a row
right so it's it's max it's time to show
if he's got me maybe fabi's time to you
know I'm getting fired yeah we are game
five knowing that Magnus does have two
whites in a row that means you're if you
fritter away your your third white then
suddenly the guy comes Bing and Bing
he's looking to hit you two games back
you're gonna be under pressure so this
might be the moment to really bring out
whatever you've got just try to hunt
this guy down that ain't gonna be easy
though and I have a feeling Fabi doesn't
feel that kind of pressure by the way
I'm we're describing this narrative this
guy's probably feeling fabulous well one
of the things they do have a free day
we've seen to rustle emo Sicilians I
haven't been that impressed exactly by
what White has gotten but Bambi sounded
really comfortable like that he felt
that he had something in a second white
so perhaps we're gonna see another
Russell I'm a Sicilian and that's just
the way it's going to be I'm gonna go
with it now you're gonna I think you can
opener or some other type of anti like
c3 close to something different then we
got a whole free day to take bets on it
and we will see you on Thursday coverage
is gonna begin at 9:00 a.m. central
that's 10:00 a.m. Eastern and don't
worry Maurice is gonna come running in
at some point early in the Brock bro is
suitcase aside and give us the rundown
on the games and of course on Trevor
Noah
absolutely thank you for joining us
everyone we'll see you Thursday
[Music]
[Music]